the following is a presentation of the
St Louis chess club
[Music]
hello everyone I'm former US Women's
Champion and wgm Sabina for sure I'm
very excited to welcome you to the Third
Edition of the Karen's Cup this event
features 10 of the strongest female
chess players in the world let's go to
the studio and get the action started
we welcome you to the Third Edition of
the Karens cup one of the richest
women's tournament in chess
we come to you live from the San Luis
chess club
good morning and welcome everyone thank
you for joining us I'm International
Master nazify kids and I'm here with
Grandmaster yasu sarawan Nasi it's
wonderful to have you in studio again
and for what a tournament normally I
like to make an editorial comment but
I'd really like to turn the stage to you
and to tell our audience why this
tournament is so important for women
globally and also most importantly for
women in America please right yes sir
Karen's cup what a tournament I mean
it's one of the strongest and most elite
tournaments in the world and it has a
big price fund so all the young girls
watching inspiring players they can
watch their role models these top female
players compete in the such prestigious
event and it's motivating for them to
continue to play chess and become strong
items and GMS like these players here
it's amazing to see in today's Chess
World women have such fantastic
opportunities and there we see the
ladies talking together very happily
before the games and tell us about the
past winners of this Kearns cup let's
take a look the first Karen's cup Was
Won by a Russian Grandmaster Valentina
gunina and I remember her Victory so
well she was doing excellent she kept
winning game after game it was great
watching her and in 2020 Grandmaster
from India hampi conero was the champion
and she's returning here as a defending
Champion well tell us about the roster
of players
right our top seed and returning
Champion Grandmaster humpy koneru next
we have Grandmaster Alexandra castanoke
former world champion welcome back
Alexandra another Indian Grandmaster
Harry kadronavali
Georgia's number one Grandmaster Nana
zagnita
Kazakhstan star Grandmaster Jan Saya
abdumalik German's number one
Grandmaster Elizabeth pets wow another
strong player from Georgia Grandmaster
Bella Hotel Nashville
young star from Azerbaijan International
Master gunai mamazada that's easy for
you to say
eight-time U.S women's champion
Grandmaster Irina crush and the
four-time U.S women's champion
International Master Anna satonski it's
incredible to see Irina and Anna as the
lowest rate of players in the field it
goes to show how incredibly powerful
this tournament is tell us about the
format as we see the players coming into
the tournament Hall they're getting
wanded they pass through a security
check with the format right it's going
to be a 10 player round robin tournament
where players are not allowed to offer
any draws okay the time control is 90
minutes for first 40 moves 30 minutes
rest of the game and 30 second increment
from move one exactly and this schedule
for this event there will be trial of
nine rounds and the players will begin
today round one and on Thursday June 8th
they will have a rest day five rounds in
a row four rounds is a Sprint to the
finish and it's amazing we have a
historic first is Almera you are the
first lady who is Ever taking the post
of taking control of the chess engines
it's a fearsome undertaking be brave
bonjour
welcome to St Louis bonjour yes
such a delightful tandem to watch first
of all Nazi is bringing a touch of
delicators
and yes it will I know that you're
sensitive to flattery so I have two for
you your deliciously funny and your
eloquently resilient wow thank you so
much also for pointing out that well I
will embark on my own space odyssey to
where like no woman has ever been so I
hope that I will tame this Beast you
know honey it will go well and let's
have a look at the Players to watch in
this tournament
you have Grandmaster Han piconero the
top seed of this event she is the 2020
Karen's Cup champion the defending
Champion she represents India and she is
one of the few women who's ever crossed
the 2600 rating barrier
following we have Harry cardrona Valley
her Fallout team wait they just won the
bronze medals at the world Chesterland
put together but here she's going to be
her rival she is rated over 2500 25 10
and she represents Hindi as well so she
won twice the bronze medal at the
women's world championship this is quite
a result
and next we have Irina crash the
American Legend she won the U.S women's
Chess Championship eight times so Catch
Me If You Can if I might say
and well a lot of wonderful and talented
women in this field I can't wait for the
games to begin and now Mira would I
describe the players as Gladiators
Warriors
Amazons what word would you pick of
course Amazon's The Fearless yes and uh
just for the pleasure of contradicting
you
that's what we have event Nasi do the
honors tell our audience what they can
expect in the first round matchups let's
take a look first round pairings we have
the former world champion Alexandra
castenuk playing the defending currents
Cup champion
matchup is for today yes then we have
Hurricane Katrina Valley against
Elizabeth
petsada against Bella Hotel Nashville
easy for you to say
against
Irina Crush we are expecting Fighting
Chess throughout and what will they be
fighting for they'll be fighting for a
lot of money the total prize fund for
this tournament is 180 000
and the first place winner is going to
get forty five thousand dollars second
place thirty five thousand third twenty
five thousand a generous prize fund all
the way down to the sixth and last place
10th and last place which is six
thousand dollars sorry as we get ready
for this first round we see our
Fearless Amazons
uh getting ready for the first round and
this is our Marquee matchup as we have
former world champion Alexandra with the
white pieces and their top two states by
rating companies number one and
Alexander's number two which is
something we will get into very shortly
as we start to decide our picks as to
who we expect to win this competition
and uh well we'll be asking and
answering that question shortly as the
rounds get ready to get underway we get
a very nice Coca-Cola bottle there is
actually a place to the right of the
players where they usually keep their
drinks because of the webcam at the
cameras we like to keep a nice clean
View at these
Furnishings the tables are actually made
here in Missouri a Furniture Carpenter
put them all together with dgt boards
and it's really really nice with this
green felt it's a cushion so that the
elbows don't I absolutely love playing
on them right right and we're really
trying to make the most quality
conditions we can the players are
actually playing at the World Chess Hall
of Fame which is across the street from
the St Louis chess club and Scholastic
Center as we
um
uh we're going through a reconstruction
right such a beautiful plain haul I was
lucky to play there at the American Cup
and like I said last time it's my one of
my favorite places to play chess it's
playing in a museum gives you this uh
feeling that this is a special thing
Amira in this kind of competition which
is such a
pop-up competition butterflies in your
stomach as you get ready to start the
game well actually this is one of the
questions I wanted to ask the players
and I will do so but I remember that
I've been there myself you know and well
you're torn with fear the first rounds
are a clear indicator of your form so
um players are anxious let me just
interrupt you and say Jeannie sinful the
eponymous uh name for the tournament
herself it's her maiden's name uh care
so Jeannie is going to be ringing the
bell starting the round
is the co-founder of the tournament
absolutely of the chess club and all of
the chess campus
we're hearing some announcements
[Music]
the clocks are set so that you get the
30 minutes once you have once one of the
players go down to zero they use up all
the time so you will not get the 30
minutes when you pass the 40 moves but
it will uh you will get the 30 minutes
once one of the players use up all the
time on the first time
uh reminder there's no drawer who will
attract so please don't offer at any job
you can only draw that can be during the
game is playing the three-fold
occurrence or the 50 move rule drop okay
um
after all first
game conversation if you would like to
analyze your game here yeah as the
that's due to telling uh the players the
no draw offers but you were saying
Almira the butterflies they're in your
tummy but when did they go away
well I think when you make the first few
moves and well you will know what
opening did you expect it or not and
then the creative phase of the game
starts and you forget about everything
because just players they need an
absolute concentration I would call it's
almost a trance in order to play a
perfect chess game so they forget about
everything right absolutely agree with
Almira I have same experience before we
make first moves I'm so anxious I'm
aware of everything happening around me
and then we make the first move and
everything else disappears exactly this
just completely uh disappears
as we see the players there
comes the rainbow and there's Genie she
looked happy yeah cheering in the first
moves yeah
um
I noticed and I I thought that was kind
of intriguing we saw the players before
the round and they're very very friendly
we actually saw
um uh Irina just at the board there and
she was talking to her opponent like you
know everything okay with you
and I must say I didn't really engage in
small talk before the game I kind of
like to be focused how about yourself
did you like unless I'm playing my
friends right then we have a little Chit
Chat yes right okay as we see
okay we see the Italian with Bishop C4
uh by Alexandra in her game with humpy
no Bishop B5 Bishop C4 and that has
become
crazily enough this has become the Hot
Topic of today's chess when I was in the
Scholastics
we played it because that was what
everybody played we were kind of taught
by our coaches but what's what what goes
around comes around and it's suddenly
become the fashion Knight F6 inviting
Knight G5 the two knights defense no
thank you d2d3
um go to move as uh
this game gets underway Almira this
whole
I want to say uh Italian game the quiet
game has really become a trend why why
does it so attract why is this so
attractive today well actually I play of
course this opening myself but first of
all I wanted to tell you that there is
already a slight surprise on the second
move because I was expecting
hampicronera to play the Petrov meaning
here and this is the opening she used
against Alexandra many times so uh well
first surprise but Alexandra recently
plays jokopiano so this is the Italian
of course which happens after Knight C6
and Bishop C4 you develop your Bishop at
a very active Square then Knight F6 and
yes you're right really said so so white
is invited to play Knight G5 you know
attacking the F7 pound of course black
has two counter attacks so you have to
sacrifice a pound and here you have
this very strong move so why it has to
continue and after C6 did take C6 B
takes C6
well you have a few moves you can say
Bishop B2 Bishop D3 so this is a rather
complicated position uh black is playing
for initiative and I think that this
position is rather dangerous for white
so that's why Alexander declined this
line and she went for a more quiet line
which happens after D3
uh and normally you know black can
continue with Bishop C5 or Bishop E7 and
why why chooses these lines because you
have so many plants which are easy to
play very often you will play C3 like uh
let's say C3 I just demonstrate the
plans then Knight D2 and I will make
some move then Knight F1 let's see G6 or
number Knight G3 then A4 and expand B4
so this is the position which is easy to
play and and most of the time you know
like about 15 to 20 moves in advance
because you're there is nothing concrete
happening another surprise which
happened in this game is that humpy went
for D5 immediately so she is going for
one of the most concrete variations in
this line uh let me have a look
so if we have any games yes I can see
that the ecbn country beat visit in 2022
so the most important um move is it
takes D5 as it happened Knight D5 then
you have Castle they are still following
the main line so rookie one and F6 F6
looks quite strange to me I don't play
this with either colors and it just
looks very bad to me but I assume it's
okay well you have to defend this phone
and unfortunately you have no choice
let's see if you don't play F6 because
you cannot play uh Bishop D6 Queen D6
looks very artificial you know I think
that after Queen D6 you have a lot of
options
um but the computer like I don't know
what computer computer suggesting 93 but
maybe even after Knight D2 94 your queen
is very awkwardly placed on 26 so you
have to play F6 and then I think that uh
well hampi is Asking Alexandria question
what do you do next okay we'll keep that
game on the boil as we go around and we
look at some of the other games
I tell you the ladies are coming here to
fight I'm just looking at this game
between harika and Elizabeth King's
Indian defense you know that is going to
be a very very tough of fighting game
King's Indian defense has a reputation
of uh challenging white you you build up
a big Center E4 D4 C4 and then black
tries to tear it down we'll keep an eye
on that one to point out irina's game
Irina Crush we know she loves to play
the Sicilian and she's in shy away today
we have browser variation on the board
one of the sharpest lines with Bishop on
G5 so this is going to be in
intense fights exactly and I remember in
the candidates where uh in the final
round
um probably needed to win against Sergey
kariakin and he chose the Rouser and it
was a brilliant Rook Sacrifice by Sergey
that denied
um Fabi from becoming a challenger again
Bishop D7 this is uh also I want to say
Almira a topical line at the very very
highest levels of Chess a lot of amateur
players don't like the strategies that
these kinds of games and entail but what
is the current uh thinking about the
Rouser is it a A variation that's very
popular very successful for the white
player the black player what's the story
the sixth and actually here uh hesitated
and rightfully so because you can play
F4 but you can also play F3 and go for a
more standard plan which was used before
so after three there is well there is a
plethora of moves you can play Bishop B7
you can play B5 there are many moves
possible moves Jean Sayer went for a
more critical line so F4 and I would say
I would qualify it is a more aggressive
approach to this position and black has
to be careful computer already evaluates
this position as a bit better for black
but nothing serious because this is
still the opening phase and computer
very often evaluates the positions after
the opening is a slightly worse for
black so Bishop B7 was played and blacks
is simply intending to finish the
development and of course very often so
with the positions with opposite castles
you will have have
a very dangerous attack of course from
both sides because black will play B5 B4
and then
white at some point might actually take
on F6 I was thinking about this
possibility so let's say after Bishop is
seven I wanted to show you a small line
because it comes from like my childhood
can you win a pond here so I just wanted
to check it if you take Bishop S6 Bishop
F6 then Knight C6 Bishop C6 and take
and say queen D6 and this position is
actually evaluated is much better for
black even though black has just lost
the pound because you don't know you
don't exchange Quince you will play
Queen B6 and black has sufficient
compensation and two Bishops so you
should never enter this line of course
no I've caught few players in this line
with black
I used to play You're making a trap yeah
so so here yes it's Knight F3 the main
move Knight F3 is the main one very good
one of the criticisms that I've had
about Anna satonski in the past is that
while she's a great player she's won the
US Championship four times I mean that
speaks speaks for itself she mismanages
her time in the opening especially she
spends a lot of time five minutes ten
minutes
considering moves that she knows are
very standards here she is is white
uh uh we just seen move Knight F6 is a
very very standard Queen's Gambit
decline position
everybody's been playing Bishop G5 for
years if you don't like Bishop G5 the
alternative is Knight F3 and if you
don't like them apples finally the last
one you can take on D5 but she's sitting
here thinking and burning a lot of clock
or clock and we know those minutes
become so useful later in the game when
you are in a Time trouble why is she
consistently burning her time no I've
played against her many times and we
were teammates at the Olympia yeah I was
the captain I'm biting my hand I will
tell you I was sitting right next to her
every day and to watch her clock after
about 10 moves that she would be in time
trouble was so stressful right but she's
good at it I think that's her signature
she spends a lot of time but then she
plays very well even in time trouble
exactly I don't know why she is to do
that but she does it well so Amira has
time trouble been an issue in your chess
career well not really I was always
playing rather quickly but I know Anna
since we were kids and actually I think
well it's uh it's a very interesting
feature I think how you play chess
demonstrates what personality you have
so I think it's it's one of the most
difficult things in life to make choices
you know and here especially when you're
playing the chess game and you have to
well to make a choice which could have a
heavy influence on the game course is
very difficult so I think that Anna
feels
better when she's in time travel because
she's forced to make those choices nice
and in their head-to-head matchup how do
they compare with one another let's take
a look
right so wow uh Nana has a big lid with
six wins oh my goodness you were saying
that herika has been an awkward opponent
for you yes for Anna apparently Nana has
definitely uh he likes that they don't
even have any draws no games wow oh my
goodness okay maybe that's why Anna is
taking her time here on this move just
want to go to the game of Elizabeth uh
for a moment this was the king's Indian
and actually the system that harika has
chosen the overbox system with Bishop E2
was a big favorite of mine like I really
put a lot of effort into this system and
castles Bishop E3 this is almost a
combination of a overbach as well as a
gligarette system I'm going to ask you
did you ever played with Bishop G5
yes yes that was my that was actually my
primary move in this position was Bishop
to G5 I like to provoke H6 and then
bring my Bishop back Bishop E3 and this
move by Elizabeth is a real stunner for
me
A7 A6 I've always thought that black
can't really hesitate and black is
required to play the move C5 why do I
find the move A7 A6 a bit of a challenge
well if I start to play Super aggressive
suddenly and I want to play the four
pawns attack in the four pawns attack
you you you're not allowed to hesitate
you're not allowed to waste the tempo
and F4 is really the challenge but that
wasn't what she played Almira Knight F3
was on the board is on the board pardon
me and is this all standard Fair well I
actually like this move A6 It's A
peculiar looking move but it is actually
she asks harika a question because after
Bishop E2 very often you want to play
this nice looking move you know but here
a computer already thinks that uh black
has a very nice well a slight Advantage
because now you can play C5 and maybe
after D5 you already have prepared the
move B5 and now you can understand the
idea behind the move A6 yes and it's a
very important inclusion so after A6 of
course you can play a very elegant and
more organic move oh sorry there is six
is Knight F3 and this is actually the
main move in this position and here I'm
wondering what Elizabeth has prepared
because I think that she doesn't want to
play E5 maybe she's looking more for the
move Bishop G4 right
is on the board already I'm also
considering maybe Elizabeth wants to
play C6 and kind of like Pierce opening
yeah don't show yet your hands whether
you're gonna play E5 or B5 right I
remember here in St Louis it was like
the ultimate move and I don't know how
they they got me to play Gary Kasparov
in a five-minute game it's like dudes
I'm like what are you doing to me and
Gary played C7 C6 castles B5 and got
what we in America popularly call the
Burn System
attributed to Grandmaster Robert Byrne
and the idea is to play Bishop B7 in
Knight D7 a very unlikely sequence of
moves for a king's Indian but you're
absolutely right c7c6 is a quite a
legitimate move here I don't think C7 C5
works very well in this particular case
after C5 I do believe I can capture the
pawn and again thanks to the fact that
a7a6 is on the board black is not
getting hit of the usual compensation
that she should expect from the pawn
sacrifice so we'll keep an eye on that
game now see what what games caught your
attention
oh excuse me but I think we have a very
special guest in the studio with Almira
let's jump
that's true I have a very special guest
please welcome genius and Gifford Cairns
The Mastermind behind this tournament
genius just tell us like how did you
came up with this idea because I know
that you support a lot of scientific
events classical music events and then
the chess event well basically the real
real people behind the scene was
Joy Bray
and Shannon Bailey and they decided we
needed a top women's one
then they decided they had to name it
after me because we had the sink field
so that's how it happened you know
because we wanted one that celebrated
the best women's players
and this tournament is about to become
traditional we had a small break through
into the historical this was the third
time in a lot of the players actually
they've come here three times
I think we only had one who had never
been
was I think yes so she's she's playing
the tournament for the first time so how
does it feel it's it's good it's it's
interesting when you watch the women's
games versus the men's games
it's different they tend to be
in some ways more interesting because
they're not playing you know you're
memorizing thousands of old moves and
they're all of a sudden you you find
these things that they're
emptying the board you know what's
happening and so it's just a different
style
which I enjoy you know fireworks yes on
the boards yeah fireworks yeah and from
what they've seen in the previous
editions of the Kevin's cup they there
were a lot of decisive games so the
percentage was skyrockets and at some
point you were having more than 68 of
the decision yeah it was like someone's
gonna win you're not gonna
you know try to play to a draw you're
playing to a win and if you have to do a
draw you might but you're going to try
to win Virginia and I wanted to ask you
about your book read and write chess and
I also contributed in a small way to
this it translated you translate the
French please tell our audience about it
and about the purpose okay the it's a
booklet where you can start with very
young chess players to teach the
literacy in other words how to read and
write chess what are the letters for the
pieces what's the location for the board
what are the how do you write down the
moves because you could I could play
chess without reading and writing but if
I want to get better if I want to play
in a tournament if I want to be able to
read a book or even replay my games
I have to literacy and since I served
that chess merit badge what we were
finding we had what three hundred
thousand Scouts that were in the
chestnut badges the kids aren't in the
right place they're not maybe in a big
city that has a big chess influence
there are no coaches you know of course
so I wanted a broader group to be able
to learn
you know what Wesley so did taught
himself by learning and literacy and
then I don't know we
got translated into one language and now
it's in how many languages more the last
ones were okay Romania okay that's
Christian shower right he just persuaded
the uh
Ukrainian I'm sorry Romanian we also
have Ukrainian okay Romanian Chess
Federation to use it in the public
schools
because the learn to read and write
chess besides being available in all
those different languages is free
you get a
there we go that's the English version
okay there's we got Uzbek Armenian is
new
Romanian
Russian Swahili English French German
Indonesian Filipino Romanian
we have to find another exotic I just
need to you know I find
Grandmaster chess players or high chess
players who
come to me and then they put their name
on the front
so now we're teaching chess literacy and
in Eastern Africa this is a very unique
future and Dutch and Dutch and
Georgia's wife did Death
so that was it's fun and because we want
to find and grow chess players from
around the world
yes I agree with you that's fun I
actually tried it with my own daughter
and you know yes we did the whole
project from the beginning Until the End
yes and she helped you make it a better
booklet right how old was she well she
was seven at the time yeah she this was
a seven year old helping her write it in
a seven-year-old it's designed for
children you read write say move all the
literacy and and the other is it's just
it's going outside of chess
in St Louis there was a former football
player NFL
Demetrius Johnson I just got away he
coached four high school football teams
he required every football player to
learn to play chess
because he felt it helped them visualize
to improve the pattern recognition well
remember you got this set of moves okay
we're going to play this route right
sort of like a chessboard
Jenny I wanted to ask you a question of
course everyone knows that Rex is so
passionate about this so are you well
tell me how do your games go you know if
you play from time we start playing 50
years ago okay he's a I don't like to
lose and he's a terrible loser
so there's no upside for me if I If I
Lose I'm not happy if I win
he's not happy so I'm not happy so I
don't play him I'm willing to play
others
but not him
uh Genie uh I don't remember I told him
he could do chess I mean how expensive
could it be
I think that yes sir wants to ask you a
question uh Genie it's not really a
question
so much as a compliment I just want to
say that this tournament I mean I've
been calling all kinds of tournaments
but this tournament in particular with
the top female players has always been a
great pleasure for me so I wanted to say
thank you simply it's a great tournament
thank you you have to admit it's they
play to win they do indeed they play to
win and that's a different world I don't
know if you notice in this game
you uh unless you have a three
you know thing for a draw
yeah you can't offer you can't offer a
draw in this game yeah I think it's a
very important feature although I do
believe they don't need an extra
motivation you know yeah
this is the motivation play to win
so
yes thank you very much oh I'm going to
tell people out there if you haven't
been to St Louis
or the state of Missouri you got to come
and to celebrate 200 years of the state
of Missouri
I had a eagle scout build a
5 000 pound 15 foot square Bicentennial
chessboard which has pictures of
Engravings of 200 years
but we have people playing in the
capital all the time by walking out of
the Capitol and going down to the park
yes we're finding Grove chess players
right of course San Luis is the mecca
well Missouri is it okay we stretch out
a little bit right
so thank you so much Daniel for all your
efforts and I just wish that they would
continue for many many years then and
remember we got to keep translating new
languages I'm looking for
Tamil and Hindu and
Italian and Portuguese
thank you thank you Genie indeed now
Tamil I mean we might in Hindi we might
just have the players here to do the
next step let's just jump right into the
game because these two are going at it
like gangbusters and of course I'm
referring to the game between Alexandra
and Hopi because boy after the move F7
F6 a move that you kind of said whoa uh
what is that after F6 came to move d4
and we understand from Alexander's
perspective perfectly well she wants to
put pressure on the night on D5 she
wants to open the e-file for her Rook
she doesn't want to see black just
quietly castling and completing her
development so D4
and the players played very quickly like
humpy said I expected that move so cake
the bishop the bishop remains
firmly on this diagonal go ahead please
take my pawn and your king is going to
get caught in the center I may point out
their times at this time neither of them
have spent any time so both of them are
in their preparation yeah they just and
again they kept blitzing their way
through all the way to this position and
then after Bishop F4 the obvious uh
point is that I'm going to take the pawn
if you if you try to maintain the pawn
oops right we'll be very happy white
will be very happy that was a whole
point of rookie one and opening up the
e-file she can't do that and hope he
said no problem you can have the pawn
and I will solve my King's prob
development my Kings uh
a home with the move King D7 after King
D7 I developed because you're not
threatening to take my Bishop I'll take
your Bishop on E7 again the players were
playing all of this very very quickly
this is all standard Fair Bishop takes
and as you said Bishop takes B6 and
giving up two Bishops
yeah unless I'm unless there's a very
very specific reason I wouldn't have
done it myself I would have more most
likely if I had reached this position
for the first time simply retreated my
Bishop but I I do recognize that Bishop
takes and here after a move for example
like Knight D7 I'm very very quick to
put pressure on the pawn and Almira is
this again the players are playing very
very quickly is this the state of modern
Theory well this is the state of modern
Theory and Bishop B6 isability because
they were following the game between one
Forest Jordan against Arjuna regasi and
94 was played in this game so Alexandra
deviated and she decided to take the
Knight on B6 let's say actually let's
have a look what is the difference when
you played 94 I think that's uh well
Bishop E4 is not really like a
possibility because then you can take on
B6 and then you want to play this end
game because if you will take Bishop B6
then rookie 4 and even though you have
an opposite color Bishops I think that's
why it is much better and the computer
actually confirming my intuition because
like it's not so easy because this
bishop is actually much more active than
this one when you have troubles
evaluating the position ask yourself
what is in your pieces potential and
then so if this bishop is much better
than this one especially with the Rooks
on the board this position is much
better for white
and even though you still have a few
drawing chances you don't want to defend
it against the former world champion
this is a risk-free position
so uh
Alexandra she didn't want to play uh
after Bishop C5 Knight E4 maybe she
analyzed this position and especially
that she plays in the same team with the
Jordan one first so it might happen that
they analyze this position together so
she went for Bishop B6 which is a
novelty here
but the computer is hesitating Bishop B6
here so uh what happened in the game is
ab6 let's see what can happen after
Bishop B6 then you have this very
important inclusion you can check Bishop
A4 and where do you go because if you go
King seat and this Rook is completely
out of play and then okay maybe you can
go for this one Knight F3 that would say
I will try rookie seven as well yes and
The Rook is seven yes your white pieces
are very active like I've just showing
the ideas that's why hampi took on B6
with the pound and then she still has a
shelter maybe with like King C7 after
Bishop A4 but what to do here after
Knight T4 is in the game here you can
see that the bishop is protected so you
have an extra move so maybe that's the
difference the small nuance and the
position
for that yeah
um again because this is such a key
matchup between let's face it our two
top seeds
um
the tournament in some way and the very
start of the tournament can be
determined by the outcome of this game
which lends itself to the question who's
gonna win who's gonna win we're gonna
have to make our choices
yeah right now baby before the outcome
of this game is known because it's going
to be such a crucial game ladies first
it's a very difficult choice for me
right first of all I have so many
friends playing in this tournament it's
very hard to pick and they'll hate you
for it and so many players that I've
been looking up to Growing Up and
they've been my personal Heroes so I'm
gonna go with the top seed ham piconeero
as my pick a defending Champion not a
bad pick at all I'll Mira I'll I'll give
you the floor well I have the same
dilemma and I was thinking
um well against which player I'm having
the horrible score in this field because
I've played almost against every player
in this field well then I will have to
go with my dear friend Alexandra
questionnuk so well I think that the
fight between these two players is going
to be ferocious wow well I'm gonna share
the stage with you on this one I think
Alexandra is eternally young a former
world champion every time you don't
become a world champion without having
that Fearless Amazon spirit that is so
quite necessary so Alexandra even though
she's the second seed yes but I look at
this field and I say who can win it's
certainly wide open with and we have
varusian our production team member he
likes homie as well so right now we're
kind of split
we're gonna have to ask Sabina to be the
army getting tiebreaker if she would
like and uh we'll jump right back into
the game a game we haven't seen is
Bella's game
um and it's this this
um what the moroxie buying position
Knight G4 it's a it's an old line peace
blender uh
hold on yeah you you don't do it when
the bishop is on you can just take on G4
so she has mixed up her preparation
because Bishop takes e Bishop so the
black takes back right in between moves
so the the the the standard and what I
played against Boris Goku as black in
the U.S Championship as Knight G4
Knight G4 in this position Queen takes
G4 Knight takes D4 is the very very old
popular main line but in this when you
have the inclusion of the move Bishop E2
the difference is you're not supposed to
be able to play Knight G4 because I have
Bishop takes G4
and if Bishop takes back I have Knight
C6 that's the Intermezzo that's the
swishin zuk Knight takes C6
oh my gosh his yeah
mixed up her preparation
well I think that's uh bill is
struggling with the jet lag and this is
a real blunder it's just a real blunder
right because I I try to understand the
intricacies of this position but there
is nothing to say you know it's when we
analyze something you know where we're
looking at art for example I can't say
that the beauty is in the eye of the
beholder but here the truth is in the
eye of the computer after 94 you simply
take on G4 it's a blunder it's a huge
blender
so I'm sure she just mixed up her
preparation and I think you just hit the
nail on the head when you said it was
jet lagged because I jet lag can really
just mess you up and the Knight G4
you're supposed to play it two moves
earlier and in this case again Bishop
takes G4 you don't have to recapture
your Queen's under attack you don't have
to recapture the bishop because then
Knight takes D4 and black is fine but by
playing Knight takes E6 you take my
queen you're welcome to it I take your
queen you can take my knight you're
welcome to it I'll take your Bishop fish
I don't even have to give you these two
pieces two pieces for The Rook I can
simply move my rook and yeah my knight
is going to escape
um the attack so this is just a blunder
Yes actually I had to look at the games
and I've seen the seen that there are so
so like more than 22 games
yes the the 22. it's a very common
blunder it's an oversight and Knight G4
we do have Bishop takes G4 on the board
number forcibly reminded of our Women's
Championship the Armageddon game between
Arena and Jennifer where also we saw a
blunder on the G4 Square it's like okay
there's a blind spot going on there a
lucky day for gunai yes we don't think
so I have a question for you actually
it's a very interesting Moment Like of
course not from the chess point of view
but from a psychological perspective
what do you do here do you resign
immediately or do you make a few moves
just to regain your composure and well
it's a very difficult situation well
you're right it is a very difficult
situation but I never resign and I'll
tell you why because there are
um many many chess authors out there of
Chess books that want Miniatures they're
looking for games that that are finished
inside of uh you know 20 moves so if you
resign after 12 moves you're going to be
featured in a miniature and not in a
nice way until you play to move 30.
you're going to remember that right
watch out don't lose a miniature you're
going to be immortalized but you're
right psychologically you feel terrible
you just want to resign you want to get
out of there and you say what am I
thinking so yeah it's it's a very
difficult and in their personal
match-ups I can't imagine they played
that many times Well there it is four
games and it was evenly split two wins
for good night to win for Bella and
looks like no draws today Guna is going
to win another game wow yeah but a
common error intriguing that 94. let's
just again quickly the Marquee match up
Knight E4 is on the board by of
Alexandra and not much has happened
since that time I'm going to go around
the horn with harika and by the way
um
a knight G4 by Elizabeth so after Knight
F3 934 right now Bishop G5 H6 I would
imagine Bishop H4 and again the these
are very kind of common ideas in the
king's Indian defense but I'm really
beginning to look at scans at the move
A7 A6 like A6 necessary how does that
fit in with exactly what black is doing
is this uh still are we on theoretical
Battlegrounds Almira well I wouldn't
call it a theoretical Battleground
because I think that the inclusion of A6
especially with Knight G4 because I also
played this line with black is a bit
strange so we still have one game after
Knight G4 but okay it was not played on
the top top level even though uh vedemus
wagensive was playing with black and I
think he what he tried on this game is
to confuse his less experienced opponent
so don't try this at home
yeah
and after Bishop G5 you know the
computer evaluates this position is
already is plus one so it's it's quite a
serious Advantage right and the
inclusion of H6 uh Almera in that
position has been played I want to say
yes and then Bishop H4 which isn't has
not yet been played how would the
computer continue
after Bishop H4 for black because
I don't like Black's position actually
well the typical would be to play of
course Knight D7 or 96 than to play E5
but you have this bishop manage four you
know it doesn't allow you so very often
when you have the bishop on H4 uh
players try Queen E8 but here it's very
dangerous because you have nine
different let's say you will make a
blunder in this position with Queenie so
you can play Knight D5 attacking only
seven and on C7 you know so you cannot
uh do so so no no no and then after
Bishop H4 I think that you will have to
make a commitment you will have to play
G5
wow yeah that looks uh dangerous uh to
my eyes for black just wanted to jump to
the game of Arena Crush for a second uh
because this was the open Sicilian game
that we looked at and we were looking at
Bishop takes F6 but we saw the position
here F4 Bishop E7 and the players have
kept up to date with Theory obviously uh
Knight F3 B5 Bishop takes F6 now this
idea of munching the pawn on D6 actually
forcefully requires this recapture GTX
F6 which is again very very standard
stuff F4 F5
two things to say about this move F5
the first thing is if you look at this
Pawn structure it's actually very good
defensive construct entire Center yeah
all the squares so you have to make some
kind of it inroads and this move F5 the
idea behind the move F5 is to actually
weaken the pawn on E6
exactly to get the D5 Square for the
night exactly and you really would love
to see black actually just capture this
Bond because that would mean that this
Outpost is eternally in White's hand
finally another good point of the move
F5 not always but there's the sneaky
move Queen H6 that could be very very
disturbing for the second player which
is why H7 H5 was played by Arena just
stopping any ideas of Queen H6 King B1
kind of tucking the king and on the
queen side Queen A5
in Bishop D3 castles let's take a look
at irina's clock one hour 31 minutes she
has more time now than what she started
with this is she started with 90 minutes
she's got 91 minutes on the clock Amira
I think it's fair to say that uh Arena
prepared this position it was black but
what do the chess engines think of the
current position with the King on B7
well I haven't looked at the engine yet
curiously because I well I wanted to
offer a human perspective uh of course
you would evaluate this position as a
slightly better for white because you
have the space advantage and you know
your the black species are a bit clumsy
I wanted to understand what was the
difference between Queen A5 here
actually and queen B6 because here you
can also play Queen B6 and here the main
move is G3 like a castle again and
Bishop H3 is a very interesting move and
they would continue this King
but these are very old games classical
games I would say so in the game what
happened the screen A5 and the computer
of course evaluates it is a bit better
for white but Arena knows the plans
because she knows it's a slightly
inferior position but she knows her
plans and the moves so she uh after
Bishop D3 here white blood pressure long
Rook 81 King B7 we would
I I would put maybe the King on B8 you
know so because they're still following
an only game that they have but played
by the amateurs and after Queen F2 this
is the novelty Queen F2 is a novel
previous to Queen F2 Almira what was the
standard
only one it's only one game yes
yes well it's uh let me see Bishop F1
was played in this game and it looks
very strange to me so Queen F2 Bishop F1
all right very cool we'll keep an eye on
this and of course uh our shows wouldn't
be anything without your participation
we refer to you the audience and we'd
love for you to send us your questions
how can they do that nothing all right
please join the conversation you can
send us tweets or comments on Instagram
YouTube twitch at St Louis chess club
and if you're tweeting please use
hashtag Karen's Cup right try to stump
our panel of experts we take all kinds
of questions and uh is Sabina going to
be monitoring the chats I believe so
Sabrina will send us the questions
lovely and she made a pic she did and
her pick is our Legendary player Irina
Crush well I gotta tell you I mean I'm
talking friendships here Arena crash
indeed eight-time champion and that
whole Almira Catch Me If You Can
your ref difference there was this idea
that you've been the seventh time a U.S
a French Champion or pardon me so you're
trying to catch Arena but you're way
behind way you're so far behind I don't
know if it's possible well actually you
know Nazi was talking about the source
of inspiration and I really find it
inspiring you know so I'm I will try to
catch Arena maybe not this year but
exactly the next year hopefully nothing
how about I mean I know you won the
Women's Championship twice but you were
very successful in the youth World
Championships yes okay did you win have
six gold medals
and five silver
let me join the conversation here did
you guys know that I once beat the
Seattle City Champion
I mean I'm not kidding it was a
celebrated match too everybody your
opponents were Gary casparo he wasn't
the champion he had all the time but
yes sir it's time to bring the Soviet
Union and the telegraph March I think
right right those were fun those were
finals on the appeals committee wow okay
as uh round one is fully underway but I
tell you this big breaking news is that
in the Sicilian uh our
I want to say rookie player I don't
think he's ever yeah yeah she's never
been in St Louis before she's been given
the gift of a minor piece she she uh
Bella misplayed the opening she played
Knight G4 apparently a common mistake
that has been played 20 odd games in our
database and gunai is a piece up she
looks like she's cruising to Victory
Alexandra and hunpi the number one and
number two seeds coming into the
tournament are playing each other in our
opening first round and we have I want
to say a kind of a balanced position
would you like the two Bishops or do you
like the structure unless he jump in
this position I would prefer white
because because of the Paw structure and
even though black has two Bishops one of
them C5 is not a great Bishop that's not
a great bishop and I'm worried about the
D4 Pawn because it is an isolated
weakness in this case and white could
possibly win that in the end game so
exactly now it's not my cup of tea
either but uh Almera was saying there is
a possibility of a Bishop's of opposite
color notice that by capturing with the
B6 Pawn the desirable Bishop A4 check
isn't uh playable if you do take yes you
will win control temporary or otherwise
over the e-file but I gotta think this
is much closer to a draw but it is a lot
more pleasant to play with whites right
you'd rather have the Sunny Side if you
will all right and jumping to you Almera
did you have any games that caught your
attention thus far in round one uh thank
you yes sir actually I wanted to talk
about this position because uh hampi is
still thinking and you know uh it's a
very complex position to understand
because you know black has to make a
move but first of all you need to
understand what is White's idea after
Knight E4 of course I don't want to take
95 let's say I will make just a
ridiculous move you don't want to take
it to simplify the position but I think
if I if I make a more natural move like
uh Rook E8 and attack this Knight so I
want to play Knight G3 it's a very
strange looking idea but I am playing
against this bishop because the bishop
on B3 is rather powerful and it's
controlling you know the diagonals or
after Bishop j6 I think that Alexandra's
idea is to play H4 winning the bishop
after H5 and after trapping the bishop
Basics so strange five to stop the
uh the idea there yes but after age five
of course you have an additional
weakness here so in this position you
are playing on two flanks you have
already weakness on D4 it will not be
easy to defend it so I suspect that
after each five you will trade Rooks
maybe trade another one and try to win
either discount like Bishop C4 Bishop E2
I will not see for your possibility to
defend it right so you should be very
careful uh while thinking about those
Mercy that explains why humpy is
thinking for such a long time it's a
completely different positional concept
intriguing uh very much so yeah what
audience might think that is a very
equal position so positionally complex
yeah that quiet Road Waters Run Deep I
think we were talking about the other
day uh looking at the game of Anna uh
and Nina for a moment because finally
Anna zatonski that has kind of sped up
her play she did decide on the Move
Bishop G5 Knight B8 D7 all very standard
captures captures E2 E3 C6 Bishop D3
Bishop D6 and Anna has sped up her play
and they've reached this rather I want
to say standard Queen's Gambit decline
position with the bishop on G5 often
times you're looking at F3 and E4 is
white
um I think Wyatt has two main plants F34
as you mentioned and another minority
attack on the queen side with Rook B1 B4
A4 B5 and so on right and then finally a
line that Wesley so has been
experimenting with and that's a long
castles with the idea of uh G4 and with
the Kings on opposite sides of the board
then the players go crazy and try to
attack one another's Kings yeah well
that's that's uh Fighting Chess uh
absolutely to be sure and jump in on
this uh well I want to say quite a sharp
position Almera after the move Queen C2
what do you make of it well I have a
here because you want to know like where
is this bishop going Bishop Bridge four
Bishop F4 and actually yes sir I wanted
to ask you what is your preference here
before I tell you what is the favorite
move in this position after age says yes
I will go with Bishop H4 Bishop H4 so do
you find Bishop F4 less natural here
yeah I like it yeah less natural for me
I mean especially I put my opponent in a
pin I want to maintain the pin that's
the most natural move for me so uh
Bishop H4 is the move which was played
of course a number of times and here
well black continues with rookie which
is a very standard plan and especially
given this structure because Nazi
mentioned the minority attack of course
so if you Castle short then of course
you will proceed on the Queen's Funk
site and then white black will try to
put the piece on e4 which is very
important but here
beware that after Bishop H4 that's
exactly what I wanted to tell you that
you cannot Castle here you know because
you have this idea Bishop H2 King H2 and
then Knight G4 you know and so this is a
very complicated uh analysis of course
computer goes for this uh line
immediately and here he simply plays
Knight D of six so have a look at this
position
opens up the bishop I would be terrified
here with white I understand Al Amira I
have a question why King H3 and why not
King G3 right oh King G3 let's say King
G3 here because then I think G5 is
coming so uh let's have a look so Knight
G4 King G3 I think that you still have
Knight df6 and then also G5 is coming
with Tempo trap in the bishop so you
will have to take here Bishop F6 because
in the other lines you're keeping your
bishop and after Queen F6 you know
that's uh there are not so many
squares around your king which are safe
so I don't even know how to so computer
line is E4 you know something completely
crazy is H5 you know which is not
obvious defined and then computer goes
F4 so and the valuation is slightly
better for black after Knight E3 but you
would have to assess the all the
intricacies of this position before you
play castle so it's it's a very
difficult decision oh no question about
it and walking into those uh we we call
them Greek sacrifices but Bishop
sacrifices they're very very challenging
for the first player yeah I I can
understand that after age six Bishop H4
Rook E8 you would want to include the
move H through H3 and not allow this
bishop the downside of including H3 is
that if you are planning to play F3 and
E4 you don't want the pawn on H3 no you
don't yes we can too many black Square
around it exactly and if you wanted to
play those lines that Wesley so has been
playing you won a castle so that maybe
you could play G4 and G5 hopefully
without you know including that tempo of
h2h3 well as we get prepared for our
first break of the day I just wanted to
make sure that we had looked at all the
games uh
yes Elizabeth did choose to play C6 but
then the inclusion of Knight G4
that looks a little bit uh obscure there
Knight to G4
um one of the nice things
I love both the black side as well as
the white side of the king's Indian I
think that it brings out the best
strategies for both players one of the
downsides or even put it another way
a major downside of the king's Indian is
the fact that white often plays for an
attack on the queen side and the move A6
and C6 the combination of those two
moves is severely weakened the square B6
so we all know what we'd love to do we'd
love to put a knight on V6 with the
Knight on G4 I would find myself very
attracted to the move Knight D2 well
what is the idea behind the move Knight
D2 well very straightforward I like in
Bella's game I want to take the night I
mean give me give me the night and if I
provoke the night Retreat let's just say
for example most logical move then I
find myself drawn my eye is drawn to the
move C5 why well because again I do want
to establish my night on uh B6 uh it's a
little bit I wanted to say crude but I'm
just saying those are the types of
things that I would find myself doing as
white
and as we get ready for our first break
that usually means that we've got to
jump in with our friends at uh right
across the street at the World Chess
Hall of Fame and Q Boutique and find out
what is their special of the day well
here we have it
take your roll-up board and chess pieces
in style with the official St Louis
chess club logo travel bag the zipper
pouch holds an entire set of pieces
comfortably while your board fits
underneath gold screen printed ink in
durable vinyl don't forget the chess
pieces and vinyl roll-up board for all
your chest shopping needs do check out a
cube Boutique St louis.com and as we go
on break we asked the Players yesterday
as they got into town what they thought
about returning to St Louis and here
there
[Music]
how does it feel to be here in San Luis
for the Third Edition of the Karen's cup
yeah I'm very happy I played first one
and after after a break we are playing
like 31 and we're happy to be part of it
it's the strongest tournament in the
world with huge price on and I'm really
glad to be invited ah Mitch feels good
it's my first time in us and in St Louis
so I really love the atmosphere and I
really love the venue so I do look
forward to play as soon as possible
well it's great I was actually surprised
when I got the invitation because for
the second tournament I didn't and I was
really upset so when I saw the email I
was very happy and I and I mean I told
to my parents like okay I would like to
sometimes again
yeah I'm very excited and I think this
time it's a quite a different field with
lot of mix of egg players as well
and definitely this is one of the
strongest women tournaments and also
with the highest price fund ever
so I think it's going to be quite tough
for everyone I'm so happy to be back
here I mean I'm so happy that the
Karen's cup has resumed after a couple
of years you know
um of a break from the for the pandemic
and um yeah it's a very special
tournament I mean it was kind of
formulated to be one of the strongest
tournaments for women in the world and I
think it's going to be super exciting
I'm always very excited when I'm getting
invitation from Saint Louis and I'm
really very glad that I'm still here
after three years of break and yeah I'm
looking forward for a wonderful
tournament I'm really excited because
after three years we all are here and we
understood the value of it after
pandemic and to give importance that we
are here all healthy and playing the
tournament so definitely I'm really
excited that the strongest ornament
Karen's cup is back with the Third
Edition and yeah I'm looking forward to
be part of it so it's a long time
year it was 2018. my first visit to
Saint Louis and I had very good Memoirs
despite of my playing so I hope I hope
that this year will be more
interesting games for me and I think
well very well here I'm delighted to the
time here because I like this club very
much and this atmosphere everything it's
um it's really nice to be here again
um first of all like I was very happy to
receive the invitation almost in the
last moment because I think I was one of
the last participants to join the event
but yes I remember my time in 2019 even
so I think back this time I got the last
place not sure but I think so
um this time I hope I will do a lot
better I mean at least like to get
somewhere in the middle would be nice
and yes I am very happy that when I came
here today that I could recognize so
many things so nothing really changed
and it's still the same Spirit like
looking at the hall of fame
so I'm really excited to start actually
I'm very very happy and very excited I
was very looking forward to coming back
because we had this
um three year long Gap and you know
every single year we like got emails
about the possibility to be back and
then somebody didn't quite work our way
so I'm very relieved to be back and I'm
very looking forward to playing again
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
hello and welcome back to our coverage
of round one of the Karen's cup as the
games are underway and it's actually a
kind of a funny moment in the game of
g'day and Abella
Bella blender to piece full stop and end
of story except for one remarkable thing
the position is actually still Theory a
lot of players have blundered the piece
in exactly this way of course black uh
is down a minor piece a lost material
the game is over there's a few things
though that white has to be careful of
like for example if you were to play in
this position Knight D5 as for for
instance your Knights might get a little
bit messed up I think that's a decent
move but after E7 E6 97 shag King eight
they should you know the nights look a
little bit weird awkward but still yeah
it shouldn't be very comfortably winning
for white uh we're going to jump also to
the game of Arena Crush for a moment
this was the Sicilian Rouser yeah the
Rouser and the last moves few moves
Queen F2 uh and Rook C8 Knight E2
deserve comment these Pawns in the
middle of the board are really making it
awkward for White's pieces so white has
to find better squares for the piece
this Knight in particular is looking at
the D4 as well as the F4 PS squares as
being Outpost and really you want to put
a lot of pressure on the E6 Pawn I think
the position's still a little bit
balanced now see how do you feel about
that I'm going to guess the computer I
would still prefer white because of the
space Advantage but I personally prefer
black could be biased because I used to
play this right but I like that black
can actually start the attack on the
queen side even though Black's King is
also on the queen side yeah the King on
B7 looks actually pretty safe and the
half open C file is an invitation after
all for Black's pieces uh I like the two
Bishops as well I kind of see it as a a
balanced game
um continuing
um
because uh intriguingly Almera pointed
out right here what we would what would
we like to do and we were looking at
ideas of maintaining the pin with the
move Bishop H4
intriguingly on a light Bishop F4 Knight
and then moved Knight B6 Amira that's
actually a novel move uh yes yes sir let
me show something before we get to this
very interesting novelty so after age
six uh your preference was of course
Bishop H4 and we analyzed the very
interesting line so that after Rook E8
you you didn't play H3 so Castle then
Bishop H2 King H2 it's a very
um nice sacrifice so now it's G4 now
both of moves are possible King G3 and
King H3 but I myself I asked okay let's
say uh King G3 and what happens after G5
yes sir can can can you tell me what is
why it's best movement
take the peace you are absolutely right
you know and it's the only move in
moving position to claim the advantage
but you have to play King G4 look at
this position it's such an unusual
position and especially so early in the
game you know a computer evaluates is
plus 2.8 so it's a huge Advantage but I
wanted to ask you I will give you an
opportunity please attack with black yes
so what you do this well I would sit
there and say first of all a good
General leads his army into battle and
the thought here is with the King on G4
the bishop on C8 there ought to be some
nasty double check right 956 95 Knight
F6 would be the first moves that would
bring to my eye uh so let's pick one yes
yes Knight F6 and the Kings gotta go
back G3 but I don't know the computer is
fearless of course it doesn't have any
emotions I would I would be so scared in
this position you know because you can
blend under at any moment but he even
suggests King gives three because that
okay King G3 is the best move in this
position so he doesn't even take a piece
you know it's because Queen D6 is also
an option you know because after Queen
D6 you know you have to play uh well
four F four yes but he thinks that after
Knight F4 because you have to take I
only wait four years only one that's
only possible and this is a huge
Advantage it's plus six for white wow so
you see so after Knight F6 if you don't
play Queen D6 you take on H4 but then
you can find the shelter because you no
longer have the screen H4 check so after
King H2 Knight G4 you simply go back
King G1 or King H1 so actually there is
no attack and no Queen H4 uh very very
insightful uh but tell us about the
novelty for a second yes let's have a
look at the Novelties so Bishop F4
actually was a move that was played uh
quite a few times and first of all from
a strategical point of view you want to
exchange this dark Square Bishop against
this better Bishop on D6 so it's
actually a very Sound Idea and uh very
often you know a black would play uh
Bishop F4 yes Knight F4 you know it's
it's a very natural cancellation and
then rookie eight or Knight B6 here
so we have to understand what is
actually the difference because Nana
probably wants to take on the six with
the queen so she thinks that the Knight
F4 is actually a very powerful piece so
she decided to use this idea and after
Bishop F4 she played Knight B6
immediately
so I think that this is a very natural
move in this position
um yes Bishop D6 Queen D6 and uh let's
have a look what is their difference in
this position Queen is on the sixth so
if your Castle you have Knight G4 let's
say castle so maybe you have moves like
this or first you prepare the attack
rocket and you have this resource a bit
later right so Knight B6 okay no
question is great please uh since you
are familiar with Wesley's long Castle
yes Ken white still go for that after
night B6
let's just take a look so uh Knight B
yes like right now so first of all often
times when white does Castle
A5 A4 B5 B4 are very standard ideas for
black the the Black Knight on B6 might
be considered actually in the way like
not the ideal Square you're only looking
at Knight C4 I notice already that h2h3s
on the board one of the reasons I like
Bishop G4 is because I was playing for
G4 without H3
Anna has played H3 and kind of kept her
it's a it's a kg move she's capture
options open she's neither committed
herself to short nor long castles and
she's basically saying I I'm gonna I'm
gonna hold my cards right I like what
Almira was saying rookie ate in so many
positions is such a useful move the Rook
is on the half open file often times
you're fighting for control over the E4
Square so I like rookie eight and
eventually Anna's gonna say okay I'm
going to go longer I'm gonna go I'm
gonna go short I wanted to go to the
game of Elizabeth and herika for just a
moment because we had a very different
approach by her Enrique she just
canceled she's keeping C5 and the bands
uh what's going to happen B5 Rook C1 and
this is a very different approach by
harika bit she's keeping everything open
she's also intimating that with this
move Rooks he want she's eyeballing C6
why is that important well we're going
to make a poor move for black and just
to show you one possibility that herika
may be thinking is that oh now we start
to see that the pawn on C6 could be a
Target and the black will have a
difficult time developing Queen side
exactly so I like harika's Choice by the
way I think Rook C1 is a very good move
and now let's saving the best for last
let's go to the Marquee matchup that we
like between Alexander and defending
Champion I think we have the position
that alamir I was analyzing exactly and
this is what Almira was advocating for
was the move H4 so the idea is I'm
threatening to win a piece H5 this
bishop on B3 patrolling the long
diagonal there is well A2 diagonal is
controlling H7 and if we play for
argument's sake age five to stop uh
White's H5 then as Almera was suggesting
um the the bishop on G6 kind of Tethered
to the pawn on H
5 we might for example see a move like
Rook takes E8 King takes E8 King might
come uh once again all white needs is to
maneuver the bishop to the other
diagonal precisely and then H5 Pawn will
fall precise so Bishop D5 Bishop F3 you
just want to make sure that A2 and C2
are protected and that's why H5 I I
would want to avoid playing H5 as black
H6 on the other hand maybe I feel like
I'm giving up
too much space
um Rook E5 just to give the bishop a
different Square
these are some difficult questions that
I think H4 poses the most problems for
black Almera is that a fair assessment
yes I completely agree with you and
actually I'm still looking at this
position and the more I'm trying to
grasp the the sense of this position the
more I understand that this 94 Knight G3
is a dazzling idea because it has so
many
so many different ideas behind it as you
rightfully said you don't want to play
H5 even if you play H6 I will still fix
your structure but actually maybe you
should consider it because I think that
after the best move with computer gives
rookie 5 I think that you can still play
H5 let's say okay you have a better
Square for your Bishop but still I will
go further I will go which six and I
think that I'm going for all these
weaknesses you know so if you take a GTX
H6 I was thinking that you know that
this position has more holes than the
Swiss cheese you know so they're they're
you know weaknesses everywhere so I
think that's Alexandra's idea after Rook
E5 so what to do here H5 you have to
play Bishop E8 H6 and I don't think that
you have a better move than she takes H6
here because Knight D4 is coming and
attack so let's say rookie one
rookie one and then you still have to
react and you will take a night well GTX
C6 and then Knight T4 and computer
thinks that white is slightly better but
with a long-term initiative black has
four Pawn Islands here yeah that is uh
that's swiss cheese and I happen to like
swiss cheese I mean just not at the
board uh just something to think about
them by the way uh we did invite you to
join the conversation and I want to
encourage you uh more as I'm waiting for
a good challenging tweet it's been a
while it's been a while actually I have
a question for our viewers may you
submit something you know we were
talking about space odyssey and I think
that our computer doesn't have a name as
you all know in Kubrick's movie it was
whole 9000. so would you be so kind to
make your suggestions what should we
name our silicon Beast ah
uh a big chess Enthusiast it was uh the
director of Space Odyssey uh by the way
um
yeah good name for a chess Beast
chess engine a Hydra yeah well let the
audience decide yeah by the way uh we
are breaking historical ground as always
here in St Louis and the Karen's cup is
a perfect fertile got ground to to do
something unusual and we decided for
ourselves that our best guest deserves a
bottle of champagne so when the players
come on and they're all capable of
playing brilliant games they will have
to explain to their public what their
thought process were
you guys are going to be the judge but I
want to invite the audience to help you
in your decisions who's going to be our
favorite guest at the end of the
tournament because they're going to get
a bottle of champagne the first time in
history
the best guess and yes remind me it's a
very good bottle of champagne it's a
very good bottle of champagne I promise
you there so as we uh again our audience
is going to have to assist in my
particular case I I disqualified myself
because I have a terrible weakness
I'm a sucker for flattery
and all Arena has to do is say hi yes
sir and she's got my vote that's it
I'm easy H4 on the board uh Almira and
uh how is humpy gonna deal with this uh
you said rookie five H5 H6 could could
cause discomfort uh go a little bit
deeper than that
yes let's have a look at this line
because I think it will happen on the
board so H5 Bishop yes it's a critical
moment of the game already so Bishop 8
is the only move so H6 we were
considering the move rookie one so let's
have a look if you do not exchange the
Rooks and you will take uh GTX H6
because I think that after G6 after 94
you know uh White has a huge Advantage
because you know you have this crucial
weakness because if you play Bishop B7
here then I might as well go for for
this Pawn as well so you can play Rook
G1
you know it's not so easy to defend
everything
and then so after age six let's have a
look at GTX H6 you know right and see if
there is any difference okay you might
keep the Rook on E5 so it would give a
shelter to your king maybe in some lines
so but I would still go Knight D4 here
what is interesting about this position
that's black is facing a difficult
choice at every move and a white spline
is crystal clear so it's much easier to
play for why this position even if you
have a slight Advantage you know black
will spend more more time on each
decision
so after Knight E4 I I can't even see
what is the way for a black to defend
the pawn and F6 computers suggest to
give it away immediately He suggests
Bishop G6 Soul Knight F6 and then your
team D6 is 66 yes you have to go there
to protect the rook in E5 and well it's
still much better for white and this is
also the position where Alexandra excels
she is she has a huge tactical site and
she calculates like a machine
thank you uh Almera for that yesterday
we were having it wasn't an opening
ceremony as much it was a meeting of the
players as well as the drawing of lots
and we have some shots from yesterday's
opening ceremony I must say the players
were very very friendly to one another's
like everybody had a story that they
wanted to tell of their most recent
outings it was a very pleasant yeah off
the board they're all friends it's only
at the board when they become Fighters
there we see Joy Bray by the way
welcoming the players very beautiful
necklaces and bracelets drawing of the
Lots the numbers were on the other side
I was very very tempted
to take a look at the numbers uh yes sir
did you get your necklace as well no no
I missed out there was only 10 of them
and I felt very
unhappy that I I couldn't I couldn't
snack one I mean I got extra no way I'm
going to talk to my agent this is
extremely unfair very very very unfair
as I wanted to tell you yesterday
actually had to say I I like those
images so much because well quite a few
years ago maybe more than 20 years ago
when I won the European Championship my
opponent didn't speak to me for two
years really who was your last round
opponent it was actually a terrible
tiebreaker that they end because so I
first had to play Alyssa galama and then
Katrina kovalevska so that they had to
beat those incredibly strong players in
order to win the title right one of them
just didn't speak to before several
years I tell you sometimes you know
chess is a very very brutal Sport and
emotionally losing a chess game can
really be devastating uh today however I
must say this game between uh good night
and uh Bella uh Bella's gonna feel awful
because I don't mind losing at Cheska I
really really don't especially when my
opponent has played well then I just tip
my hat say good job but when I play like
an idiot then I'm really furious with
myself because I didn't force my
opponent to play well and this is what
happened and this is a very very
standard position
in the moroxie bind and everybody knows
the move Knight G4 Queen takes G4 Knight
takes D4 and my 60 memorable games Bobby
Fischer
talks about this position with Knight G4
but there was an inclusion of a couple
of moves
and now Knight G4 is just a blunder a
blunder that has been played 20 games 20
times I'm a strong players and what's
the point the point is after Bishop
takes G4 Bishop takes G4 we have the
inclusion the swishons of Knight takes
C6 we don't have to take the bishop
right away we take the queen and at the
end of this series of captures guess
what you're a piece down okay there is a
small small smidgen of counter play only
because this
long diagonal is a bit awkward at the
moment but once you deal with that
diagonal by for example what white has
done prepare the exchange of a bishop
is going to be gifted
earlier I don't mind losing either if I
can learn something from the game that I
lost but when you lose by making a
blunder especially this early in the
game there's no lesson to be learned
it's just that sometimes we're humans
and we make such human errors yeah and
we think that jet lag is the culprit
here uh in this one and again we just
jumped to Anna zatoski's game because we
did do have a long Castle I'm sorry okay
well there we go so Knight V6
h2h3 Rook E8 please declare your
intention as said Nana and okay you
forced me castles and again this is out
of the Wesley so Playbook where we're
castling long black is castled short it
promises an incredibly exciting clash as
white is preparing an all-out assault on
the king side G4 G5 and let's go I think
black should try to open up the C file
as soon as possible with C5
that's tough because first of all it's
not that easy to open up the C file for
example C5 at first blush you know like
like you say you know it seems very
attractive you're not that well
developed as black and you might also
regret the fact after Bishop takes D6
Queen takes D6 you're not really a video
I might just snap snatch snack on a pond
so it's sort of like you've got to
prepare that like let me help you Bishop
E6 King B1 Let's help you a little bit
further with Rook C8 I will go G4
you know like finally I get to play G5
well guess what
after takes let's say you take with the
Rook I could put my knight on D4 and
then you gotta ask yourself well did I
help my opponent or hurt because the
Knight on E2 wasn't that great a shakes
it's a little bit better yeah I gave you
a good outpost on D4 but yeah at least
black has some counter play here okay
fair fair so it is one uh approach the
the let us say the classical approach in
these positions has always been to play
A5 and A4 as black but oftentimes that
also included the move Queen A5 and here
I find the Knight to be uh in the way on
B6 Almera in this position after castles
give us the engines evaluation is the
standard stuff is it still Theory or is
it are we in novel novel uh Waters of
course we're in novel Waters and I've
been trying to analyze this position
Bishop before just happened so I think
it's a very natural move so we might
have four I think that will follow and
here I was hesitating a bit because it's
a very natural move for us to play for
example Queen D6 and after G4 to play
Bishop D7 but computer suggests even
Bishop D7 here after Knight F4 a few
things that Bishop D7 is even is
playable is for me when I look at this
position I find that this is quite an
ugly Square yes so I would want to play
Queen D6 first and what is interesting
um
here is that after Queen D6 white can
play G4 and after Bishop D7 the computer
doesn't rushes he evaluates this
position as a slightly better for white
but for example he wouldn't go
immediately for Rook G1 because he
thinks that after Rook C8 and with your
ideas to play C5 you know black is
actually better here so he you have to
make a few prophylactic moves after for
example Bishop D7 you will have to go
King B1 and it's very important you know
first king safety and then you uh launch
an attack so remember like prophylaxis
in your chess games is a very important
factor
interesting too what you're said about
these Statics and uh what is their
head-to-head uh matchup well I tell you
oh this was great even no because this
is the different players get different
players I was thinking about the Anna
zatonski there we go
wow a huge lead six wins that is
extraordinary uh in online chess when we
play Blitz matches we with each other we
say an adoption is when we win 10 games
I'm afraid Anna might be getting adopted
so we she has to be careful I I'm
looking at this position after castles
in the inclusion of the move Knight on
B6 and it's strange that for to my eyes
that the computer is only giving
a small Edge
to Black let's assist let's just go uh
to White let's just go here for a second
h2h3 let me do it in a different way
Rook to EA Queen to C C two I'm so used
to seeing the Knight on f8 so the Knight
is on fa castles and in the game we
couldn't have gotten this position
because there was a bishop takes H7 that
provoked Knight on B6 so now after
Bishop H4 A5 you would we would be on
the territory that I would find very
familiar the Knight on f8 often times
goes to E6 it defends the king side etc
etc and it's not on the B6 Square so
that it doesn't interfere with B5 so I'm
looking at the actual game position
and I'm saying well wait a minute uh the
Knight on B6
is in the way so you're thinking this is
a worse version for black a much worse
I'm singing the night on doesn't belong
on B6 actually belongs on f8 and then as
as Amira is showing Bishop takes F4
Knight takes F4 Queen D6 King B1 Bishop
D7 G4 Rook C8 the computers not that
impressed and that I find
surprising a little bit confounding
actually it's like oh my gosh it hasn't
black done things wrong the computer
says no not that much wrong not actually
in the game Nana played Queen E7 instead
of Queen D6 okay so we catch up to the
with the trade yeah Queen E7 I see so
now we've white plays G4 maybe Nana
wants to play Knight E4
exactly so she's taking even more
control over the E4 Square uh with the
move Queen E7 it makes sense I I can't I
can get behind that I can support her
decision in that regards just checking
and again on our Marquee matchup h2h4
that's confounded our defending Champion
uh humpy is uh she's seeing what you've
been showing us Almira that rookie 8 H5
and H6 is an issue that h7h5 has its
drawbacks as you've been pointing out
anytime this bishop redeploys itself to
F3 that H5 Pawn is tender so there are
problems uh in the position for our
defending Champion just checking in on
Arena Crush because again a very very
big strategical dogfight going on here
between am I pronouncing and
wow just love that name Jean Saya
and Irina after Knight E2 Arena said
okay I get you I get you I see what you
have in mind you want to drop your
Knights on either the F4 or the D4
Square
I'm going to play the move
E5 and I'm going to set a really really
cunning trap what I'm going to try to do
is I'm going to offer you the D5 Square
put your knight on D5 it's a tremendous
outfit Knight C3 night before
well you can put your knight on D5
without playing the move a2a3 so
go ahead play A3 and boom uh a very
typical uh classical I might say Rook
sacrifice in the open Sicilian the half
open C file oftentimes in so many
variations Dragon variations The Rook
captures you can't capture because oops
that's just cost you a pawn
and capturing like this oh boy uh
I'm I'm getting
um uh material uh I want to say but I
feel in fact that the exchange
sacrifices I just wouldn't want to play
this position
at all and if I agreed she moved the
Knight to C1 instead of C3 okay so after
E5 the Knight went back to C1 and Arena
won something there Umar Elmira because
she won the fact that the Outpost D5
isn't being occupied uh
immediately
um how how does the computer assess the
position now after the this uh
strategical play I wanted to point
a point move played by Irina is Queen B6
offering the twin trade and actually it
reminded me of wolf Anderson a very
strong Swedish player so he wanted to
trade Queens everywhere because he
understood the end game so well so he
wanted to play then games and actually
it neutralized their his opponent's
initiative all the time and here Queen
B6 is also a very nice psychological try
because she knows that Chancey she was
strives in dynamical positions so
actually I wanted to ask you a question
that I think that John said will never
trade Queens here and she won't play it
we need to commentators curse that's
exactly and here she will just when I
was talking about it she took Queen V6
the king G6 welcome to Saint Louis this
is the way it works the moment we say
this play will never accept a draw in
this position
but what I wanted to say say for example
like then if you don't take on B6 what
is your option you just played Queen F2
so maybe like the there is a very
natural move Queen but then uh well
computer of course thinks that this
position is still better for white but
you have to come up with the plan and
what we did night on C1 of course uh
well it's never getting on D5 so so I
think that the best idea for black and
it's a it's a typical ID in this
position I want you to remember this how
do you improve this bishop potential you
always play Bishop f8 with the idea of
playing Bishop H6 right so I want to I
want our audience to remember this plant
so I think that jeansai didn't want to
lose the tempo so after uh yes Queen B6
um King B6 she played 92 back you know
she still wants to play Knight C3 in
Knight D5 but uh she well eliminated all
the opportunities with Roxy 3. nice she
got rid of counter play and in the end
game she's going for that D5 Square for
the night
this is actually a novel situation Arena
Crush thinking because uh a certain
moment in this game Nasi it was 91
minutes she started with 90 and thanks
to the 32nd increment for each move she
had made pardon me she got to 91. what's
her current uh time uh she's catching up
with John Sayer so John say has 45
minutes and Irina has 54. so the play is
definitely slowed down and this move
Knight E2 again just as we've been
talking about this Outpost D5 it's a
magnet the Knight is now looking to
bring itself back to the D5 square and I
have to say if I'm in black shoes
I don't want to see the Knight landing
on the Square
D5 so for me a very natural move in the
position is to play the move B5 B4 yes I
agree I'm giving up a square on C4 but
I'd rather give up that square like you
can occupy it if you want that's right I
can still get to D5 via C4 92 Knight C4
93. it's a long way yeah I can get there
okay so you've got ideas of check and
hear and here
yeah okay again I just feel like uh I'd
be under it I
I you need to to get squares you got to
give them and all of that good stuff I
I'd feel like I need to fight for these
Central uh squares the night on C6 may
be in the way of my Bishop maybe this
Knight should be going to the C5 Square
I love these types of fights I really do
I think that this is the Battle of ideas
is what I find personally so attractive
about Chess that and the combination I
think you know uh the combination of the
most beautiful things about Chess sorry
jump in I was just going to point out
that once you push B4 yes before it's
like a hook that I can use yes so I
could change up the pawn structure at
some point let's say after 92 Knight A5
so you can try either C3 or A3 exactly
Knight
d25 C3 or A3 only because you don't have
A5 response exactly
I'm you know uh so many typical ideas
including Pawn sacrifices that I've seen
uh in these uh arousers
um again
um a typical ideas that I've seen
uh not so much Bishop C6 right but you
know just playing Rook take C3 in
playing a positional exchange sacrifice
so even in the end game you would
sacrifice an exchange
yes if I didn't you know if I felt that
the fear of Knight D5 was greater than
the loss of an exchange especially if
you give me a pawn for it you know like
you know if I take that A2 Pawn off the
board and I feel really happy a little
bit here with black and how do these two
players match up
their head to head wow
jeans has three wins and Irina has four
wins
talk about uh playing for the fences
here look at this no draws between seven
games no draws wow
um Even In classical chess I mean it's
sort of like uh do you experience that
yourself that uh your your games tend to
be far more decisive than well I am one
of those
players who makes a lot of drugs okay
good but I've played against most of
these players in the field right and uh
yeah our results are always win and lose
win and lose this okay very very
intriguing uh this game of Arena crash
our marriage just uh jump in there for a
second because I I proposed
uh maybe uh something a little bit
flippant but I propose this exchange
sacrifice good or bad well actually uh
yes sir I wanted first to comment on
posed in this position after night it
too before and I wanted to tell you that
your days are numbered
because you know I love it
because well actually a computer agrees
with Nasi here and I this C4 square is a
crucial square of course Knight G2 is an
incredibly strong idea but even after
Bishop C4 you will have to deal with
this spawn and you will have to play
Knight d8 or Rook H7 you know those are
not the moves that you really want to
play because you you are fighting for
some kind of counter play here and then
what I wanted to say that uh you were
also right on on a butt but you know you
were right about something here because
after Knight E2 you know
you could try actually night before
because this is a very interesting way
of course to protect the D5 square and
you can take on D3 or Play Bishop C6
here so you know that after A3 you can
take Knight D3 she takes D3 you change
the structure a little bit but after she
takes D3 actually black is better that's
what I wanted to tell you so of course
you have to take here with the Rook oh
sorry 93 Rook G3 but you know you you
even if you play Knight D5 here I think
that you you might hold here so after
Rook G8 you know I'm attacking this
pound let's say G3
okay you make some of the king C7 you
need to protect the spawn and after
Knight D5 you simply take on D5 that's
what I wanted to demonstrate even though
you have this a very passive Bishop for
the moment after Rook D5 you can
well simply play Rook G4 or improve it
at some point and wait right
I think this is this exact position what
Almira is just showing there I think is
so shocking and it goes to show what a
huge impact computers have had on our
game if you went back to the 1950s and
you showed a very young Bobby Fischer
that final position where the Knight
versus the passive Bishop you say what
kind of player are you this is a
terrible position for black you can't
play like this in the engines have
actually taught us that there are many
bad positions or positions that we
thought that were bad that actually
quite holdable that one being one of
them that the passive Bishop is uh
underrated overrated or however to say
it that the position is actually
playable yes because there are a lot of
defensive resources but I wanted to have
a look at this position and at the move
Knight E5 that you proposed and here I
wanted to take a boat so to make a
computer actually proposes the move Rook
C3 we take C3 even in the end game and
then he's going for a knight B7 and
Knight C5 you know it's like okay this
is the uh sound ID here
so you may state
well no I just like the fact that uh
well I got a small measure of
Rehabilitation on that
my days are numbered we're talking about
AI chat and how uh pretty soon the the
chess engines will become commentators
and we'll all have our user interface I
I tell you I'm still looking forward to
some discussions from our some questions
from our chat but where would you like
to go in uh our games
yes I really like her position as we
discussed this opening why it's doing
quite a while but after after sorry 61
yes and Rook A7 I'm not sure about K7 I
think everybody more or less goes for
the 97 Bishop B7 setups uh this move
seems to suggests
that Elizabeth would rather see her Rook
defending the epon and allowing her
Queen perhaps to go in any case a2a3
harika said okay whatever you're
planning it's not going to include B5 B4
I'll display A3 to clear your intentions
no intention Knight back to F6 Knight
back to D2
and we've caught up that way I think
it's just very hard to continue to
develop for black right and why it has
so many good options I love space I've
always been a big fan of space both
sides too white already dominates the
center right but you could dominate the
queen side with B4 or play on the king
side with F4 oh wow F2 F4 uh almost like
the Anna satonski game where you're
going to Castle short are you going to
cast along where do you want to play uh
castles uh pardon me on the queen side
or on the king side what are the times
the two players harika has 45 minutes
and Elizabeth 38. pretty close well good
we're just going to take a very short
break and we're going to come back and
we'll see you on the other side of the
break see you soon
[Music]
foreign
season bursting with comedy's romance
and Magic Begins June 12th with the muni
premiere of beautiful the Carole King
musical
the Epic summer continues with Disney's
Beauty and the Beast chess West Side
Story Little Shop of Horrors rent and
Sister Act
single tickets are now on sale at
muni.org
St Louis the chess capital of the United
States it also plays host to an
award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in store and online from quirky
greeting cards to luxury chess sets
there is something for everyone at Q
Boutique enjoy a shopping experience
like no other make sure to check out Q
boutiquestl.com for a wide variety of
gifts for everyone to enjoy
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
welcome back everyone we are viewing
round one of the Karens Cup yesterday
the games are underway and the fights
are at Full Throttle as we are looking
at the game between Alexandra and punti
uh the fight between number one and
number two and humpy the defending
Champions been caught on the back foot
and this move Knight E4 uh by Alexandra
it's a move that we've spoken about for
some time is really putting the pressure
on black the structure just looking from
a structure point of view all of these
Pond Islands what you were saying Nasi
uh really makes it awkward and the chess
engines as Elmira has pointed out is
saying okay just go ahead give back the
pawn yeah you've got these Pawn islands
and yes it's ugly but on the other hand
we've got the two Bishops
we can hang there if you will there's
some activity that a Block's getting
exactly a great fight that I really am
enjoying is uh the game uh between Arena
crush and again sorry
a big big big battle over the Outpost
the fight for squares as we just saw a
queen trade
um Knight E2 here we come we want to
play Knight C3 Knight D5 and Arena says
I see you and I'm going to cut you off
of the pass I'm going to play Knight E7
challenging uh the square
challenging control over the square D5
Rook pardon me Bishop F1 threatening
Rook takes D6 Bishop to C7 defending the
pawn and now as we were just coming on
air we were saying to ourselves I we we
like what Arena's done I mean on a good
day you get to play Bishop C6 arguing
that I could play D60 five I could be
better just like that I mean if if Arena
can get in Bishop C6 and rook d8 and D5
she'll solve all of her problems have
two Bishops on an open board even now
without the D5 implex position looks
completely safe yeah it looks very
comfortable and furthermore the King on
B6 not a weakness at all uh in the end
game she's ready to fight for for a big
fight and finally uh before I turn
things over to Almer I just wanted to
check in on the game of Amazon tonski
versus uh Nana and in this game it's
sort of like even though the kings are
on opposite flanks thus far with this
last move especially Anna is basically
saying I am not
pot committed I'm not going G4 G5 and
crushing you on the king side in fact
I'm going to take my time I'm going to
control any counter attacks that you
might have based on the Move C6 C5 and
eventually I will uh greet you just
being prophylactic very very much so
and uh Almera Let's uh turn to you uh
for the Elizabeth arika versus Elizabeth
let's have a look first of all at the
position where we left the game and
after A3 you know I was trying to
explain a little bit the psychological
battle uh in this opening because I
think I understood that Elizabeth
doesn't want to commit herself and to
play the move G5 that's why of course
she played Rook H7 and she didn't go for
a more classical plan with Knight D7 but
then uh also for white it's not so
obvious because in the king's Indian you
usually go for E5 and it's also
about the structure then you play D5 and
you close the center here you don't have
concrete targets and I think that's what
uh Elizabeth was hoping for first of all
I wanted to review your small secret
well I got a message from her at five in
the morning awake I was like yes of
course I'm struggling with the jet lag
as well so uh players have to adapt a
little bit it will take them a few days
but uh they're playing with very little
sleep so I think she wanted to avoid
first of all harika's preparation and
that's why it's sort of capoeira style
opening you know there is no direct
fight they're still waiting but white
cannot afford to do so for such a long
time so that's why after Knight F6
Elizabeth didn't want to play G5 Knight
D2 Knight E8 harika goes for a very
concrete approach she plays D5 so it's a
fist fight now so she has to go for it
and um
for example let's say why what's
happening after C takes D5 well you can
take with both bound but I think the
most natural would be to take a c takes
D5 and to open the C file and please
look at those pieces and things it looks
like a Fisher random chest position you
know so we are in the move uh 14 but
like almost all of the black species are
on the eighth rank you know it's not so
easy for them to finish the development
here so well a computer gives quite a
nice Advantage here and you can also
play Knight B3 Knight D4 Knight C6 this
is also your golden Square
so Elizabeth decided not to go for this
position she took on C4 so here she took
uh B Tech C4 and harika took with the
Knight Knight C4 and here when I was
analyzing the position I was having
trouble to find the move you know
finding a move for black because it's
it's really very difficult and now this
Square appears to be very weak also so
you can play A4
A5 at some point so what do you think
yes sir what would you play for black
here I know I'm looking at the position
and C6 C5 I'm I'm thinking I would try
to shut down the C file but I know
that's going to invite b2b4 once again
opening up the queen side and it feels
like we're playing to White's agenda
White's agenda is I want to play on the
queen side Black's agendas I want to
attack you on the king side but there's
no visible attack whatsoever it's almost
sorry to say it this way but play on one
goal and black is responding to whites
every thread uh yes sir actually after
C5 yeah well computer consider it's
completely suicidal okay and you know I
understand why because now you have this
powerful Center you should go for F4 and
E5 how can you stop me this is like
benoni where black weight it for 15
moves and let white do everything yeah I
did yeah and The Rook on A7 might be
better than on The Rook on a but you're
right she's playing a kind of Fisher
random with all of her pieces on the
back ring a combination of big advantage
and jet lag
the worst combination can be seen in the
game of gune and Bella
oh it was really really sad for Bella
she she misplayed a moment and lost a
piece on the G4 Square early she's a
piece down and for the better part of
1600 years whenever you're heading
material the magic formula for winning
for winning the game pardon me
is simple trade pieces trade pieces
trade pieces uh and right now all white
is doing is looking for an opportunity
to trade this Rook this is this is the
compensation right here it's not much of
a compensation but the compensation is
this active Rook we could trade this
active Rook we could trade this dark
squared Bishop it's time to resign the
game and there you go gunay said now
I'll seize this opportunity she's just
played the move Knight B3 there's no
squares for the Rooks whatsoever on the
second rank there's going to be a swap a
trade and uh well uh Goonies on her way
to winning her first game of the
competition and I think we actually have
some more moves
Bishop takes D4 Bishop takes D4 she's
trying to keep her rook in the game but
the loss of this dark Square Bishop
yeah I think only idea is Rook G8 and
Bishop C6 trying to attack G2 yes that's
exactly it's very easily defendable why
it has so many ideas you can exchange
the Rooks with rookie one Rook B2 which
is one F2 she's definitely I can tell
you there's no way she's definitely not
going to allow the trade of Rook so like
she's she's hoping that she's hoping to
maintain her Rook on the second so just
as you said Bishop C6 Rook Gators are a
source of counter play and I agree with
you wholeheartedly that for example in a
position like this I might just be going
for a
trade right more trades always more
trades and trying to stop the threats
against the G2 pawn and looking to trade
and trade
that's how it goes Almira what uh
positions have caught your eye in this
the first round of the Karen's cup
yesterday
so after Knight F6 uh hampi played King
D6 the king is in the center but as you
know uh well in the end game it might be
actually become a very powerful piece
but you still need to trade a few Rooks
and I was thinking
um here because it shows actually the
depths of Alexandra's preparation I'm
pretty sure she analyzed till age five
or even age six so here you need to
understand so what are Black's defensive
resources and actually I was looking at
some ideas on how to make it work and
you have a very a lovely tactical idea
here let's say if you play G3
okay uh you might try actually D3 here
and after C takes D3 you have this move
Bishop F2 and okay you exchange a few
pieces you simplify the position and
your defense is becoming easier so let's
say after King give two you can play
Rook F5 or even Rook f8 but I think okay
five is more precise so not a lot and
after I don't know let's say King G2 you
can take on F6 and for example this
position is already equal yeah this is
much much much nicer than the current
position so you might say that D3 is
actually a threat of blacks and so white
shouldn't allow this to move G3 is wrong
and what's the right move though well
I'm not sure that uh the move G3 is
wrong because I think you have to make a
move I was first for looking at Rook 81
because it's a very natural it's a very
human move here so that's the move that
actually I would meet in this position
and then well the computer is hesitating
because this is the statue core that you
need to maintain you know so you need to
wait so maybe you can try and play the
move H5 and now white has to make a move
so uh this you will end up playing this
move G3 of course because now D3 I'm not
forced to take so let's say maybe I can
continue you know it reminds me of
Alexandra's you know uh
H4 H5 so now you played H5 and H4 and
you're trying to weaken a white
structure here a little bit of a
battering ram but in the current
position I would find myself drawn to
the move Knight to G4 not because yeah
yeah yeah yeah because we know what it
what I'm really all about I'm a pond
grubber I want to grab this Pawn but
more really I was hoping that I could
provoke a trade of Rook so that maybe I
could play Rook to E6 check and bring my
knight you know against the black king
you know take advantage of the black
king Knight G4 Almira does that uh how
would things go after Knight G4 well
actually I looked at this move and I
dismissed it before because after Knight
G4 of course I will not trade drugs I
think that it would yield whites quite
an advantage yes but after Rook G5 you
can't actually take this phone because
now after Rook f8
controlling this square right your
knight is trapped even the inclusion of
Rook E6 check is not going to make that
big a difference huh let's say Rook is
six you simply play King C7 okay the uh
the E7 square is controlled by the
bishop so you cannot continue and if you
can still try play this this is even
bigger advantage of The Rook f8 again
you've got the D3 D4 D3 idea and you're
hitting F2 and this Knight is on the rim
of course yes here it's dim yes and
indeed and Nasi I know you're looking at
the game of um of Anna satansky what's
going on uh she's just by 92. yes I'm
surprised that she I mean she's playing
very prophylactic chess okay I think at
some point white needs to go for G4
right and as time as usual a question
whenever Ana is playing uh is time
becoming a factor for her it's not that
bad no because she has more than 20
minutes left you're qualifying right for
her but 25 minutes for how many moves uh
for 24 moves 24 moves like 20. yeah
that's not terrible not terrible for her
but the move Knight E2 what you're
saying is that she found the Knight on
F4 is not ideal that maybe I think she
wants to set up to C5 to have Knight D4
move right so she's ready to uh redirect
her Knight maybe a more powerful Square
okay so she's trying to stop C5 on the
one hand is she also trying to I don't
know a trap
uh her opponent by getting the move
I don't know 94. I mean it sort of this
would work but it it's so natural for
black in these positions to play for the
move 94. what about Knight C4 because if
you don't take or kick me out which you
can do you can't I was talking about
Knight C4 well immediately yes you don't
have B3 so I'm planning to just go B5
next and B4
okay or just B5 and then see how it goes
indeed uh I thought that the night was
actually in the path of the pawn so I
would
he would take well I
I'm recognizing that you know like I I I
would be challenged let's say uh because
again in these positions
um
I respect the fact that uh I'm going to
be under uh attack on the one hand I
gave up the center since I moved to D5
Pawn so why it has E4 but here I'm
prepared against D4 exactly because I
have so many attackers if you play E4
I'll immediately play B4 and win the E4
Pawn am I hearing you right when you're
suggesting that maybe uh Anna's played a
little bit too defensively too carefully
Knight E2 uh Amira is that uh your take
on the position as well that that the
move Knight E2
maybe too quiet
I would even use another word I would
say that this move is not consistent
because they play uh I think she lost
the threat of the game and it's a very
dangerous situation for a player
especially when you're so short on time
I think that Nazi had a very interesting
idea she proposed Knight C4 here but I
would consider E4 immediately because
you cannot take here because of course
so but the thing is
I can understand
what Anna was thinking here about and
then instead of 92 after okay C8 here of
course you're preparing against black
smooth C5 so then be consistent and play
Rook D1 and I think this is a more
useful move in this position because
anyway black is going to play C5 here so
you take the takes C5 Rook C5 and okay
this Pawn is becoming great and very
important weakness yeah you can even
play Bishop Queen B3 and then you might
transfer unite to D4 when you already
have this square right
so computer doesn't like this move
Knight fe2 and he uh well he says C5
here immediately and if white takes on
C5 and puts the Knight on D4 yes let's
have a look so Rooks Rook C5 Knight D4
and he thinks that Knight A4 here is
actually a very strong move you know
using uh the pin and well we have to get
off yes you have to get B3 let's say
well he doesn't even consider them
I just wanted to get off the thing so
923 and then Rook takes and then you
have Knight E4 and all of the black
species are coming into play and he
likes this position very much the uh the
evaluation is without any appeal it's
like plus 2.3 so can you imagine yeah
yes yes minus 2.3 wow I would never have
guessed that I would have thought that
the position still quite balanced I
wouldn't think so I
wow that's really that's really quite uh
yes but here there are two too many
threads of course I'm attacking the
rookon C3 but there's the pawn and if
two there's a check on D2 and uh why it
is simply collapsing wow uh the the
tactic that I'm seeing Rook C2
would invite Rook C8 and there's a
really nice move you think I have Rook
C1
well until you see Knight D2 check and
that's a little bit
do you have this you know oh so yeah
there are a lot of tactical ideas
this is hanging the night on the floor
is hanging and then I think that
sometimes uh you play positionally but
uh everything is set up for a tactical
display so that's where you have to
sacrifice that's a tactical say this
because Nana did play C5 but I I believe
Anna's not gonna allow Knight A4 no yeah
she's black a very nice Advantage yeah
there's no reason to immediately play
after C5 takes maybe we we in this case
move our queen queen to D2 and just get
it it's also unpleasant Queen right like
walking into a night C4 Knight E4 both
options yeah
and uh at last we are about to be
challenged our audience has woken up and
joined the conversation Nasi do the
honors what are what's our uh first
tweet of the Karen's cup uh first
question is who's their favorite women
in chess upcoming Stars
oh our favorite yeah well I mean well I
I'm sorry I've been prejudiced by the
American Cup and watching Alice
watching Alice Lee go into the losers
record and fought her way right back to
the finals that was impressive sorry uh
I didn't need to steal your thunder
that's the same answer and I was the one
playing against Alice and
I'm so impressed by her she's at some
point during the game I realized that
I'm more than twice her age that did not
feel good yeah that's awkward but yeah
she's definitely a huge upcoming Star
and of course our U.S women's champion
herself uh Jennifer now unfortunately
for Jennifer I mean she's
not enough opportunity she's not
dedicating her life to chess on the
contrary she's getting her degree at
Harvard and uh
I wouldn't call that unfortunate
well I mean come on how many how many
how many graduates has Harvard had over
its 200 year illustrious history but how
many U.S women's Champions have there
been
well probably uh how about yourself
net more widely than just say american
ladies
how how about uh
the the young ladies good night and
sansaya here are they are they future
world champions
well I think it's still very early to
say but I've been impressed with the
good night's play recently especially
during the last Grand Prix I had a
feeling that when I analyzed a few games
that she
uh she gets very nervous at the stages
of the game where it becomes technical
you know she has an advantage and well
it has to become intrigued concrete and
so when her opponents defend themselves
very well uh very often uh she she loses
the threat of the game and she made a
lot of draws in the positions for
example where she was completely within
so I think that she needs to work on
this aspect of the game we all know how
difficult it is to win a winning
position of course and so
um I would say my favorite among the
Young Generation
uh well it's for the moment I think Lee
tinji well she's representing the
generation maybe in between is very
strong she's preparing against her much
again against juben June she's going to
play the match for the world
championship title and I was really
impressed with her preparation and her
play very mature
thank you for that Amira and of course
uh for me uh I felt almost it was tragic
that Hui Fawn pursued higher education
in Oxford and then went on to become a
professor but she's the number one
player in the world when she chooses to
play at least by the rating and I was
very happy that she's actually playing a
few competitions and I think she's going
to be playing in this world league
that's coming up yeah so uh pretty
pretty impressive you know I was uh
lucky enough to play Holy fun when we're
nine years old and I drew her very
very nice uh looking at the game uh
thank you for the question and indeed we
enjoy uh you're joining the conversation
uh especially uh so tweet tweet out to
us we just have this game of Arena Crush
because I'm I I'm sorry but I really
like what arena is doing this in the
Rouser this move h
4 is considered very important move it
essentially stops white from shutting
things down on the G file so the move H4
is designed to stop the move G3 so
whenever we do this big switch and we go
for counter play on the G file we
sometimes get our Ruckus shut out by the
move G3 so H4 is important inclusion
Rook D3 Rook d8 b2b3 we're caught up
with the players and uh
I would really like to play the move D5
I would especially love you to take with
the Knight so that I could get this
position yeah the problem is when I play
the move D5 right away you're going to
take with the pawn you you gain a Tempo
and then you're going to buy D5 D6 so
it's a question of how can I get in D5
where you know so let's say I played
here and I was going to say yes and now
let me just throw in a bad move through
King B2 and now I'm thinking I get to
play D5 again you can trade a piece if
you want but this is the type of of play
that I think would be very favorable if
94 is not a good move maybe 94 is a
really good move but you you know this
is the type of thing that I would love
to do as black is to get a blockade
stick my knight on D6 play with the two
Bishops and I think I'm doing great uh
but it's this fight over the same so I
think we both agree that it's the black
who's trying to achieve more than
equality here at the moment exactly and
I'm thinking that time is going to be a
factor at some point so they're on move
26 they're still far away from the time
control
and the Chance has 23 minutes Irina has
35. uh Amir I'm feeling that this game
is very tense and really the outcome of
who's going to have Advantage is going
to be decided in just the next few moves
like we're gonna just see three four
pairs of moves and then we'll know for
sure
what's your take on the current position
well you're absolutely right uh actually
black is better now and I think Irina
knows it the thing is I just wanted to
show you a small idea that you can even
try D5 here of course it doesn't yield
you an enormous Advantage but you have
this way of opening the position after
E4 Knight E4 you take Knight D5 this
position is equal but look at those
Bishops you know this uh you are looking
for a very long-term initiative you're
all of your pieces are very active all
over the black spaces are very active
but a computer likes your move Bishop B7
here even more so I wanted to show you
that you have a few Alternatives in this
position so no rush and you're
absolutely right the tables have turned
but I want it to underline that I think
that the mistake the real mistake in
this position was Queen B6 I think that
so I shouldn't have gone for this screen
trade yes yeah in this position it's
very important to keep the Queens on the
board for white because there are so
many weaknesses here so sometimes you
would go Queen F2 Queen H4 and attack
the F6 phones and this is uh this gives
uh why the balanced play so Queen B6 uh
is for me is well it's not an obvious
mistake but I feel that it's a small
positional mistake
step in the wrong direction intriguing
uh well we've got to applaud the effort
of Bella she's been fighting a piece
down she's doing her utmost to try to
and I think that's very crucial that
people understand that your role when
you're losing is very simple to make it
as difficult as possible for your
opponent to win the game put as many
obstacles as you possibly can in their
way if you say to yourself oh dear me
I'm lost and you play as if you're lost
and then you lose the game you know you
didn't put up any resistance and you
just can't you can't do that at any
level and your job is to put up as much
resistance as you can and I applaud that
in this position way back when after the
move Rook B1
black made the unconscionable the
unthinkable decision of giving up her
best
uh peace the bishop on G7 in order to
produce a situation where okay now she
has a light squared bishop and at least
she can put some counter play on the
light squares and this is what she's
trying to do uh with this last move
before and I bet you dollars to Donuts
say gosh darn it just please resign you
know like stop making my life difficult
stop putting challenges in front of me
and okay Bella Bella knows she's losing
Melody I mean there's no question in her
mind but I want for it exactly is she's
making her work for it and uh you know
that's a part about that's a skill that
everybody's going to need because you're
going to get bad positions we can't
always play good positions and how you
play when you're in a bad position is
going to speak volumes about uh your
strength that's one of the strengths of
Grandmasters they're so hard to defeat
even when you have a winning position
they put up such resistance it feels
like you have to win the game three four
times exactly and I think it was
actually uh Alexander alekine said that
about his rival uh Jose Raul capablanca
that when he beat capablanca he had to
beat him in the opening then he had to
beat him in the middle game and then he
had to beat him in the ending and even
then you know like you had to wait for
the score sheet to be signed and yeah
and it's very very very tough uh just
bringing up the game of harika and
Elizabeth because we were we're having
trouble coming up with moves for
Elizabeth Knight take C4 Knight came
back to F6 we can see that Elizabeth is
really having difficulties b2b4 okay a
little bit more Gathering of space uh
taking the A5 Square under control as
well
um after takes takes rookie again rookie
one very very purposeful move I I like
the this Rook on the half open pile and
it feels like Elizabeth is just being
squeezed and by all principles of chess
openings black should be just loose in
this exactly because Black Knight moved
five times F6 G4 F6 E8 F6 it was
questions maneuver yes move inside is
completely underdeveloped why it has a
Pawn on D5 that's kind of dominating the
position right and Wyatt has done
everything right so I want to ask Almira
what is the engine's evaluation
is white women or just better well why
it is much better the computer
Revolution is 1.6 and well it's a bit
strange that Elizabeth decided to make
this move here you know while she could
have done this before with different
consequences so and then after Bishop G3
she still needs to make a move here so I
think that you have to develop this
bishop either on B7 or on F5 so maybe
bishop B7 uh well seems awkward but you
still have to deal with this thread yes
9 95 Knight C6 so Bishop B7 is also I in
the D5 pound so after uh Jif but
especially after G5 now that if you play
Bishop B7 here maybe you can try and
play H4 here exactly exactly
I see that as a hook and their
head-to-head matchups as actually they
they have a good measure of one another
they played lots of times 30 31 times
and they have 16 draws and harika has a
bit of an edge with nine wins over five
right that is a real real Clash and I
will point out that harika's the only
player in this field who has a Peak Plus
against me right right that's four plus
five and I don't even have a single draw
oh
harika is your Nemesis yes yes the only
one yes well I was listening to yasser's
story and I actually remembered you know
that well I've read the very interesting
historical article about Alexandre lokim
and you know there was a very funny part
that of course everyone knows that he
has a he had a cat you know and the cat
traveled with him all over the world I
think the cat's name was chess yes
exactly the cat's name was chess and
what was interesting that at some point
I think it was during the chest Olympia
in Poland that the cat got lost or a
tournament so I looking refused to play
to start the game before he's cat was
found and so the police was searching
for the cat all over and and only when
the cat was found that Elohim agreed to
continue the tournament
I love that I'm a big cat lover so I
would do the same right and it was
there's also a famous quote Alexandra
alakain has come to the border control
and the Border Control Officers said
passport please and he said
I am Alexander alakine chess champion of
the world and I have a name I have a cat
named chess I don't need a passport
okay okay
we've got to let him in the thing I
don't like okay Elizabeth's game is
cramped it's it it it it it's it's sad
it's all kinds of things but the thing I
really don't like about the move G5 is
you're giving me a hook okay everything
is wrong we understand that if you want
to play Bishop F5 Play Bishop F5 you
want to play Bishop B7 go ahead Play
Bishop B7 but when you play G5 Bishop G3
and then you want to include either of
these two moves you're just inviting to
move h2h4 which could potentially open
your king side and then you're really in
trouble you're you're not only
underdeveloped your piece is passive but
now your king is under attack so the
move G5 like you say Almera that could
have come any time earlier and with a
different set of consequences but I
think it's almost like uh Elizabeth was
look searching for an idea
and somehow you know maybe this plan of
G5 Bishop G3 Bishop F5 you know I don't
know to reinforce her King side
appealed because there was nothing else
in the position that she found appealing
but I I think the move G5 really is a
culprit we'll keep our eye on that I
wanted to go back to our Marquee matchup
game between
the defending champion and Alexandra did
play Rook D1 just to avoid the D3 idea
that Almira was showing us exactly
exactly Rook A1 to D1 now is it just me
or have they been playing very slowly I
mean they Blitz through the first dozen
moves ever since F7 F6 and things came
off but now what is the times of this
place they are taking their time uh
Alexandra's down to 22 minutes and same
to for hampi it's 23 minutes as well I
think it's because there's such tiny
little nuances in this position that
they don't want to miss
and it's a nervous game because it's
such a important game number one number
two we've been seeing some head to heads
we'll save our production our crack uh
production team can come up with how
these two ladies have matched up because
again they are our two favorites and
check this out Johnny no that's not it
that is not the Johnny on the spot we
were looking for we were looking for uh
between humpy and
whoa didn't see that that's not
expecting this yeah that didn't see can
I take back my Alexandria I think I
didn't know this
Almera you didn't warn me well you're my
top agent in these matters
well I wanted to remind our audience of
course that Alexander Christina is a
former world champion and humpicroner
missed the title because she was the
Visa world champion but she lost the
match against who you find you were
talking about and that both players have
wearing signature clearance cap jackets
made especially for this tournament
I wanted to well actually I wanted to
ask you so is it made only for the
player so for example the fans all over
the world can order them online no way
these are players only baby I mean uh
very exclusive you want a jacket you
qualify for the Cairns cup you're in him
that's the way it works around here I
got a jacket for the American Cup it was
like this kind of a Letterman's jacket
with the leather sleeves boy I gotta
tell you I mean I have to fight to keep
that people come over they look at that
jacket with admiration and I keep
telling them it wouldn't fit you stop
stop looking but you're right they're
they're both sporting they're Karen's
cup wear uh Rook A1 to D1 our Marquee
matchup uh Amira
that the preparation has been you know
intense but tell us how the the engines
are evaluating the current situation
well the computer still
is a bit better for white and slightly
better for white but I think it's like
he's hesitating between two moves and
well I uh suggested H5 so this is one of
its uh suggestions but the other move
you know it's it's looking very strange
to me he is suggesting Rook d8 you know
in this position Rook date so you're
after Rook D1 you're putting the Rook on
the eight King on D6 you know this like
pound on D4 everything is in the air you
know so
is a single mistake will lead to a
defeat in this position so I actually
wouldn't try a rook d8 here but let's
understand the idea behind this so Rook
d8 I think that what he implies is that
white doesn't have any more useful moves
here you have to play G3
okay so because your pieces are on
optimal positions Knight on F6 because I
control the E8 squares so rookie one
Rook D1 Bishop B3 so you need to improve
something so you need to make a move
that's why uh G3 but maybe that's uh the
idea behind the move Rook date because
he wants to play here
yes he wants to play this yes but
computer still thinks that this is not
over so let's say
Rook F6 and well it's also slightly
better end game but I think humpy will
defend it okay so but I was curious why
is he taken on D3 because for example
let's try something different
rookie five here King E5 and that's
actually shows that's how important is
to have the Rook on Z8 now now suddenly
it's incredibly active the king is
attacking the Knight so after Knight G4
King div five
I well I'm not sure that you can take
this because after you know King G5 well
even if you get away with your knight so
now you take and if you take and I think
that now you can take here that's the
variation came over and safely resigned
so I think
maybe it's an interesting idea but well
we do have by the way while you were
speaking H5 on the board so H5 here well
very human movement preferred human move
and what I wanted to say so if you play
Rook d8 here and if you play like a
computer my hypothesis is that you are a
computer
let's let's have a look at this yes
and H5 they're more human moves exactly
yes
so I think Alexandra will spend a few
minutes pondering this move so you have
G3 but which I consider but after age
four G takes H4 this position is so
imbalanced that I really don't know what
to think maybe you can take take
activate your rook and hope for the best
okay very intriguing and let's just jump
to Arena's game because again reminding
everybody Arena was the choice of Sabina
and like Sabina must be cheering Iran
because after the move b2b3
um we looked at the move Bishop B7
uh prepping the move D5 what arena came
up with actually was just kind of King
B7 and said okay
tell me what you're doing King B2 and
check this out wow okay that was a smack
that was a little bit unexpected Knight
takes F5 and Arena's ideas is simple
whenever you have the two Bishops you're
looking for an opportunity to open up
the position and how do we open up the
position Pawn trades that's it just
trade some pawns open up the position
and after you see the move Knight takes
F5 you think well yes sir that's not a
pawn trade until you consider that after
E4 Knight takes in fact we have traded
pawns we've removed the E5 pawn and
we've removed the E4 Pawn we're
attacking The Rook let's just move our
Rook somewhere I'm not really too sure
and we can see why Arena was attracted
to uh this position two Bishops looking
terrific yeah and now takes F5 uh once
you know you see that move you settled
on the move
I like this move uh very much Almera
Knight takes it F5 tactical alertness by
Irina
it's a very fine move indeed and I
wanted to show you a small variation
after 95 it takes a five E4 of course
it's a natural continuation so let's say
I consider drug D2 it's a very human
move so it takes a free Cheetah X F3
and actually what happens after Bishop
F3 Bishop B2 once again is a natural
reply and here after
Bishop B2 rookie two I think that when
you start by playing Knight F5 and you
consider this line you have to see this
move
because you have to give back the spawn
in order to activate the bishop I think
that if you don't play this move or you
play something let's say you activate
your Rook here then well white is
already better after rookie seven so
it's as well yes it's a very important
unions that you need to foresee the
smooth D5 let's say D5 here you will
take 95 and then Bishop E5 activating
your Bishop protecting the pounds I in
the pound on H2 and then you can play
let's say after King A2 you can play H3
fix this weakness and this is a very
unpleasant endgame I would say winning
for for black already wow that Bishop on
E5 I'm sure looks good perched in the
center like that I love those anchor
squares irina's playing a great game so
far yeah she's been in she got a good uh
maybe she guessed the opening because
she seemed better and then since then
she's been out playing jonsaya so far
we'll see how Oceanside will defend
exactly for Irina Anna should we jump to
Anna's game because exactly exactly
really not like in White's position okay
when we left it it was something like
here 92 C5 takes takes Rook D1 something
we anticipated Rook CA Queen D2 takes
takes and
okay Knight F4 boy uh we were we were
critic critical of Elizabeth's night
jumping uh maybe we can be a little bit
critical of Anna's night jumping here I
I must say I I'm seeing B5 and I'm
looking at maybe you know getting out of
Dodge here where the queen trade Knight
F4 B5 we've caught up to the players
um she should probably play Queen to six
try to get rid of the queen so she just
doesn't get checkmated on the coin side
uh yeah but but let me play the uh a
devil's advocate for a moment and say
okay Anna's played the most beautiful
game of her life
and I'm just I'm I'm I'm trying to
sucker you in to playing the move B5 B4
because I do have seriously without
Queenie for check I'm I'm taking away
the E4 square with the move F3 uh go
ahead I'll turn it down to you can
prepare it before right so if your idea
is my D5 and it is
Bishop E6 or Bishop C6
okay Bishop E6 or Bishop C6 okay fair
no Bishop E6 was an easier one for me to
play against because then I can always
take the bishop and uh get out of Dodge
here Queen D6
I'm hanging the pawn on E3 but that's
not the end of the story can I can I
offer Queen trade the the story is is
that the Rook is hanging and maybe I can
dislodge the queen away from the
protection of the Rook
I would love I would love this I would
love for you to trade Queens uh I'm not
saying that uh uh I I'm better or
anything like that not even close I'm
just I'm just taking the sting out of
the attack right I mean it's like you're
not gonna you know completely Checkmate
me without the Queens on the board
um
is time a factor once again this is
Unison
I think it will be soon because they are
only on move 22 I have to live right and
Anna's down to 15 minutes now I don't
doubt for a moment that after the move
B5 Almera that Nana's happy
how happy is she after say F3 I don't
know well I may I challenge you before
anything that I have three creates an
unnecessary weakness okay actually I
would go with immediately immediately
for Queen D6 because of course well I I
want you to deprive of a very active
Queen you know it might
join the attack but I think it's a very
important defensive versus let's say
that what happens after Queen takes D6
Rook D6 I think you can include Bishop
B5 because it's some variation the
bishop might be hanging one and if you
play B4 here which is very natural so
what do you do after 95
95 95 and then this one is 97 yes so I'm
not really sure uh that you will win
this position because let's say you will
play Rook B8 and you will you will
protect the pound on B4 maybe I can
okay maybe you can play F3 actually here
because then I can play E4 but also
Knight E7 is another possibility and
play The Rook ending yeah yes I don't
know what Knight to five for I don't
know maybe I didn't see something
because computer says Knight C6 here I
analyzed it myself but now that I see
the evaluation the computer computer
thinks that white is better here so
there's a B8 made exactly after so maybe
after Knight E7 uh sorry 97 here is the
most uh precise move is King H7 so then
you can take on F5 and
mm-hmm and so here uh by the way the
Knight sees three to D5 is on the board
no Queen D6 no F2 F3 and isn't that
inviting a queen E4 check somewhere down
there the this is also ignoring the um
the concrete threats and the position
because let's say you can take your
steak and maybe bishop F5 here what do
you do king A1 King A1 and then you can
bring the queen to the attack B7 looks
like yes I think that you are absolutely
right very good
oh dear yes is there a point if Queen E4
right away I think Anna's happy to play
Queen C2 and offer Queen trade ah that
makes sense that's right Bishop S5 is a
lot more um uh precise present check B5
so here a 94 Queen E4 allows me the uh
immediate Queen C2 I like it uh Ladies
as we're getting into break territory we
want to make sure that we're going to be
here for the time troubles uh so we're
going to take a short break prep your
questions uh we want to be stumped and
challenged we'll see you at the on the
other side of the break
[Music]
the St Louis chess club Scholastic
program brings the educational value of
Chess to kids and schools across the St
Louis area active in over 100 schools
throughout the St Louis city and county
the St Louis chess club has been able to
reach over 85 000 students in both in
school and after school programs we view
chess as a valuable educational tool
learn more about our Scholastic
programming by visiting
stlouischessclub.org education
[Music]
meet me at the beauty
theory in Forest Park the muni's premier
season bursting with comedy's romance
and Magic Begins June 12th with the muni
premiere of beautiful the Carole King
musical
the Epic summer continues with Disney's
Beauty and the Beast chess West Side
Story Little Shop of Horrors rent and
sister
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back everyone we have one result
so far Mama Zara did win her game
against Hotel Nashville
blundered opening and lost a piece and
uh well there you have it I mean our
first result of the cares come came from
I want to say a combination of jet lag
and just miss
wrong move order there you go thank you
bailing me out on that one and we have
our key match up this Marquee matchup I
should say that's going on between humpy
and Alexandra and she did Almira that is
to say Alexandra did play the G2 G3 and
the King G2 idea that that uh Almera was
suggesting but after the move Knight
check we're expecting well any a king
move I the king C6 or King C7 and it
still doesn't feel like white has a grip
on the position yes the pawn structure
is ugly yes black has two sets of double
pawns but there's some activity uh still
in the position for black Dynamic play
and yeah
not play on one goal still a lot of game
ahead but we're getting set up for our
first guest
interview yes
and let's go to our first interview with
Almera uh good night welcome to the
studio congratulations on your first
Victory you know my first question would
be show me the critical moments of the
game but as we know your opponent
blundered what did you think just tell
me what did you feel when you saw Knight
G4 at the board on the board
um well I couldn't believe my eyes
because I thought maybe I'm
hallucinating because I was sleepy
um so I just had a look at the second
look and I was like okay just it's real
blunder so I felt bad for her actually
that is what I thought
but then well of course you have to take
a piece there and actually well I
suggested that maybe your opponent also
didn't have enough sleep so you when did
you wake up today yourself
um it was 6 a.m oh 6 a.m so you get one
hour more than everyone else I think so
yeah because this just dreadlock is just
joking Tunes but I hope that I will be
recovering in earlier like but I didn't
expect
uh you know I know that you wanted to
play this tournament so badly so your
dream came to True uh please tell us a
little bit about yourself how do you
feel in Saint Louis and why like this
tournament is so special to you well
um I really love the concept of this
tournament and uh the participants is
the priority when I played in the
tournament and in the place really good
chess players so and I do expect really
to play in my best part and I'm really
looking forward to the show really good
quality games and what did you feel
today at the start of the tournament you
still didn't know what's going to happen
like at the beginning of the game is it
anxiety anticipation you just want to
get over with us so is what are the
feelings
um I just was feeling kind of confused
because uh okay like there is some jet
lag and then there is some slippy mood
and I was just expecting to play it
today like a normal calm chess so to see
what I can do and she just was nervous I
think that showed itself again I think
that our audience doesn't know you that
well uh please tell us a little bit
about yourself and also about your
routine and the term how what do you do
during the chess tournaments do you
study chess from morning till evening or
well I'm 22 years old I'm from
Azerbaijan and I play for 17 years so
chess and uh what time doing during the
tournament is not seeing something
special I just checked my opponent's
games and
get prepared
and what I'm doing else nothing just
having good work that's it
actually I had one question for you good
night which might seem strange but for
example if you would be given a choice
to play only one opening till the end of
your life which one would that be and
why
um who is what color well it doesn't
matter choose like let's say with white
maybe with black and Caesar for example
to choose a sicilian but uh well like I
think it would be Sicilian and with
white I guess it would be Catalan
Catalan yeah okay there's a very
different openings can you explain your
choice because like you can't really
expect what white plans and it might
change with every game and they can make
some progresses so I do love this is
Mystery
okay and the Sicilian for because of the
aggressive attacking and stuff and I
don't know I just love the blacks plants
okay thank you so much and of course
congratulations as such a well it
started on the tournament and I hope
that we will see you more often this
studio do you know that do you know that
there is a huge bottle of champagne
which is
so maybe I think maybe Yasser wants to
ask you a question no no no no no
congratulations a nice way to start the
tournament and uh just good luck good
luck thank you absolutely uh uh in
Arena's game by the way
um
has really gone down on the clock when
we left it we saw the move Knight takes
F5 and oh boy are things going Arena's
way he takes F5 sometimes under one
minute one minute she still has nine
moves to go
then after E4 uh well this is a bit of a
curveball the move Rook D5 is
essentially inviting Arena to capture an
exchange and as shanzai is hoping that
after the trade trade she'll have enough
control over the light squares and Arena
says you know what I don't need the
exchange I like the open G file I've got
plenty of play
Visa the G5 Square as well as a G1
Square
no time on the clock irina's not a
material girl no she's not she well she
might she might still turn out to be
although Bishop takes effort I'm not a
big fan of trading necessarily this Pawn
for that pawn maybe but would it be
trading because I'm taking with a tempo
okay so you mean it takes Rook F3 right
we thought I had Bishop G4 here Bishop's
okay that but that might not be that's a
little dangerous right I'm giving up the
diagonal I I wanted to I wanted to I
wanted to take away the two bishops from
you so Bishop H3 if you were to trade
then I'm kind of feeling like the worst
is behind me
um I might think that Arena might be
interested in D5 a move that Almira had
pointed out as existed ever since Mike
takes F5 right the bishop is eyeballing
the H2 Bond the bishop is eyeballing the
E5 Square
um maybe right here I actually
funnily enough I'd like to move H3 I
also like Rook H5 Rook G8
maybe taking the Rook a little
frustrating because I don't see a very
clear
well winning routine is strong but uh I
like Arena's position but how good is it
Almira
well
um I realize a little bit better but of
course when you're uh so short on time
these positions are very difficult to
play right but I wanted to get back to
this position because I was a bit
puzzled after Rook D5 but because of
course it's um a very interesting chance
you know because she wanted to change
the course of the games on sale and
especially to get rid of this powerful
Bishop so what let's say we'll start
with it takes if three then uh Knight
Bishop D5 Knight D5 what is a White's
idea because she wants to keep the
blockade on the white squares but here
actually I was thinking what if I play
H3 first this is a very human move
because computer doesn't suggest it at
first because I don't know why he or he
wants to play Rook ht8 here but I
thought so maybe after Bishop H3 Bishop
G4 maybe I will be able to establish
some kind of blockade you know and the
F6 is hanging so but what if I start
with H3 you know he kind of likes this
move so he He suggests A4 because there
is not much that you can do and but this
this is a completely different because
at some point you can have an idea of
playing Rook G8 and Rook G2 sacrifice in
the exchange back and you know to have
this powerful Pastor so I think that
computer is right maybe you well Irina
should have taken you should have taken
on D5 yeah but from a practical point of
view given the time travel
maybe well it's not such a bad decision
uh well not to take on D5 immediately
but here for example
computer doesn't like Rook HD he thinks
that it's already given a small part of
the advantage away and Rook 5d4 is the
best move according to the computer and
so Irina is thinking right now maybe she
has to take the pound on F3
yes Rook D3 she needs to go away I think
Bishop C6 but this simplifies chances
task during the time travel right so
that's why I'm questioning uh Irene's
choice
but in that position that you've just
put on your board Bishop takes F3 Rook
D3 Bishop comes back Rook takes D4
simplified or not the challenge is still
there for white after the move D6 D5 and
Nasi I'm eyeballing Bishop E5 and that
Bishop on E5 is is lowered into the
position
Flex position looks great right I mean I
can imagine the Knight rerouting itself
I think that's why it's only option yeah
because uh otherwise you know it could
be really really good uh play on one
goal uh let me just jump to the game uh
Elizabeth uh Pates game because uh
developments are underway when we left
it we left it at this point said well I
must say uh I did not see Elizabeth Moon
and I like it very much the moment of it
appeared on the board I go oh that makes
so much sense she's trying black is
trying to do her best to alleviate the
pressure she's she does that with uh by
offering a trade she wants to see Bishop
takes H5 Rook takes C4 attacking this
Knight on C3 maybe the bishop isn't that
great on H5 and the game continued 94
takes takes and
with these trade of pieces that all came
off
a little bit easier to breathe I'm not
saying that lack of solved all our
problems there are a lot of problems
still in the position Queen C3 on the
board
exactly has not had a chance to develop
and not only that it's probably not
going anywhere in the near future either
as the this is time travels on every
board yeah Elizabeth is in time trouble
she has less than three minutes well
tarika has nine minutes for how many
moves uh for 13 moves uh oh that's a lot
of moves and we just seen the move e
takes D5 and Knight takes D5 and
Elizabeth it's not an easy position
where she can just make any Blitz out
you know be very careful exactly Queen
E6 so you said of the four remaining
games all the games have been we know
Arena uh crushes opponents and Zaya
she's down to her last minute what about
Anna and Nana so there both under six
minutes
you won't believe this Nana has less
time than Anna
whoa that we won't be saying that often
let's repeat ourselves
but I really like Nana's position it
looks pretty one-sided white never got
that attack on the king side and look at
Black's pawns A5 B5 C4
yes uh just to counter a little bit one
of the things that when we get into just
um major pieces only major pieces only
there's you know that those pawns on B5
and C4 you put the pawns on B4 and C3
give yourself a dark Square bishop and
you know you can do a dance uh with
major pieces only it's not like I'm
terrified I mean I see the attack coming
but it's not like I can't resist uh
Amira Jump Right In on the game between
Anna and Anna for a second is it a big
advantage well the computer thinks that
it's uh quite an important Advantage
especially after E4 it evaluates it it's
minus 2.3 wow I wouldn't have guessed
that this is huge but I'm like I'm
trying to understand his reasoning
because after B4 He suggests Knight D5
right and then
Queen d8 because you know it's first of
all you need to find a square for the
queen and also to keep an eye on the E7
square and here it will you have to make
a move with white as well Rook C2 The
Rook C2 but I well I have a human try
because yes I have to go back and I I
just want to exchange the trade queens
and well to transpose into a broken game
yes where my drawing chances are
probably very high width yes very high I
still didn't lose the pound and here
like he gives this variation Queen T5
and I think that's the um the um the
Nuance of this maneuver first you
because the queen was in the seventh
circle 28 94 Queen G5 and you're looking
at you know at this geometrical Motif so
after 95 Bishop D5 he thinks that's uh
here well you cannot take
with Queen D5 I don't well because of
Queen F4 and it's already minus three
you know this is what is surprising to
well to a human if I might say because
this is a threat which you can you
cannot parry and uh well C3 is is a very
important threat and so the work on C1
is hanging so please have a look at this
position it's materially balanced but
computer evaluates is plus three wow
very hard to understand why that is that
this is let's say we make some move
which doesn't make any sense so look
d2c2 yes
and then his first plane Rook C5 okay
yes yes 24 Queen D4 and then he plays C3
let's continue the variation I take yes
bit take C4 that he continues us with
the Rook C4 and actually the idea is
that when if you play Queen D3 of course
you're defends it now he goes here
so you know here and this he thinks
that's in a long in a long run you're
going to lose wow quite the geometry
um wow okay uh by the way uh because
let's say you make this and he continues
with this you know and uh now I look at
your king yes now I can see why black is
better yeah lovely piece of analysis uh
a different approach I must say by Nana
she said that after Rook D2 Queen E7 E4
you know what I'm not gonna play for B3
and C3 I'm going to play for A4 and A3
if you play C if you play A3 yourself
then C3 and I'll eyeball the A3 Pawn so
A4 a different approach you know what I
I'd be taking this bishop I just I
that that Bishop really really bothers
me D5 as well or 90 yeah something to to
to to to
um
yeah to to
simplify yeah but to stop this Bishop
from being so effective I wouldn't be
afraid of the move A3 and so I would be
seeking to trade Queens trade pieces and
Knight takes E6 on the board you said
Nana was shorter on time what is the
times uh between the two Nana has two
minutes and 40 seconds and Anna has six
minutes remarkable and for how many
moves I'm sorry uh 10 more moves 10 more
moves uh again a tense tense fight we
need to quickly jump to our key match uh
casting your corner because let's do it
Conair is now down to one minute whoa
her position is not looking good okay
things
I'm looking at the position the first
thing I'm thinking is Black's King
is really quite vulnerable like
there's almost a mating net I'm looking
at Bishop E6 Knight B5 Knight B5 Rook D7
uh after Bishop B6 what do I even do I
have to go Ro Cafe it only move yeah
okay so if we start with Knight B5 check
we've got an immediate Checkmate right
everybody's happy
you can't go to C8 because whoops there
goes an exchange okay so you have King
C6 only move and we start to see
wait a minute the uh the Contours of you
know a check meeting but I think any
Bishop E6 is going to be met by rook f8
and we're not there yet we're not there
yet it's closed but uh it feels like oh
my gosh our defending champion
won't be canero in trouble on this one
Almira yes
her last move was a huge blunder a huge
blunder well the computer was already
evaluating this position is a plus too
but after uh Bishop C5 it's skyrocketed
it's almost plus six so let me show you
the variation actually so uh Bishop C5
you were absolutely right you should
start with Knight P5 so King C6 then you
can play Knight A7 King C7 and then you
play Bishop E6 you know so of course you
that's the only move probably because of
course you don't have a choice then you
go back Knight B5 then you can no longer
go to C6 because of this beautiful oh
that's nice so that's very important
really
so you have to go to B8 and your king is
actually far away and then you start
with F5
you can't take there's a back rank mate
yes well but you you have to make
Bishop's trap yes Bishop is trapped so
you have because you cannot play Bishop
E8 because of course so after F5 you
have to play Bishop F5 and after Bishop
F5 you simply lose a piece that's it
that's it she she needs to find this uh
sequence well sequence and it looks like
a puzzle and Alexandra I know how she
trains especially how she trained when
she was a kid you know it surprised me
when gunite told us you know I'm 22 and
for I've been playing chess for 17 years
so uh Alexander has been playing chess
for so many years and one of the biggest
part of her preparation is solving
puzzles almost every day so she has this
Eagle Eye I told you I'm pretty sure
that she's going you know she knows that
there is a win in this position uh
during uh of course when we are solving
the puzzles we know that we have to
search for a win but during during the
game and there's so much pressure no one
is going you know to hit you on the head
and one tell you you know okay now you
have to concentrate but she has it she
knows that there is a winning sequence
and she's trying to calculate this right
now she started already with the Knight
B5 and there she is a former world
champion right and um the rating over
2500 right very few women have achieved
that and one of the things that I really
always admired about Alexandra is first
of all she was a very very very big deal
in the women's chassis as a teenager
already she's had Decades of really high
level success you spend at the very top
she's been on the very caption since she
was a teenager exactly and it's very
hard to maintain that's what I'm saying
exactly I did she I thought she found
Knight B5 at the start it's on the board
it's on the board King C6 I was thinking
here actually I of course like the
variation album rush out but what about
Bishop A4 because it looks so natural to
me Bishop King is completely trapped
paralyzed but do you have a threat night
Forks okay yes sorry my Rook is let's
say hanging so I need to find a square
where I don't lose my Rook on the on the
spot so let's go Roque
okay Knight D4 check Knights
I walk right into it too boy did I ever
uh you're going for this Fork uh oh I'm
I mean I feel like I'm walking the plank
I mean but I have no choice I mean I
couldn't this should be three chat yeah
I couldn't I couldn't go back and walk
into a fork so I I went King D5 Bishop
B3 check okay you're going all the way
to E4 right a good General lead a good
uh General leads his army into battle it
feels like there has to be me right but
you know 96 96.
okay well again I mean I'm closing my
eyes at this point I'm just hoping that
I haven't uh you know it's been an
impressive March but I want to play F5
here just wow but it doesn't work okay I
don't think it works if you take with
the King yes I have Fork if you take
with the bishop I have rookie one and
then Knight C5 and it should work sorry
if I take with the king I get forked if
I take with the bishop rookie one check
oh
yeah and then the Rook is no longer that
was the plan but we do have she played
Knight A7 did we have a repetition just
I just wants to gain time I assume okay
but I thought it was humpy that was down
on time so
still okay but this is the I mean this
is the moment that Knight A7 and Bishop
because once again this is such a pretty
mate it's not a pattern that you see
that often Bishop D7 check me that's
really nice and the whole idea is that
when you when you go to the back rank
I've got a a back rank mate but you say
no you don't because I've defended it
until you see the move outside Bishop A4
okay
so you're
yeah
okay uh Bishop A4 and we're gonna say
the king run
well well you you you're threatening the
double check and to take my Rook so my
Rook had to move somewhere I I went
backwards but that didn't really fare
very well if I had gone a single Square
Rook F6 like did you oh I see it again
oh my goodness it
uh Almera it's like uh canara doesn't
have a place to a convenient Square for
her Rook
uh well you're absolutely right this is
also winning move and a winning move yes
but after Rook f8 uh you were analyzing
yes 94. yeah King D5 and you were
struggling to find the wind here so no
Bishop B3 King E4 and then well it goes
for Knight to six of course so we have
rookie eight here ah okay not true okay
okay maybe Rook F6 is more resistant
because we refuted rookie eight because
of F5 no actually what He suggests it's
a very simple variation it's simply
Knight C5 uh B takes C5
because if you are going here you have
Bishop G6 and I'm threatening rookie one
so that's why he doesn't even consider
rookie right so let's have a look at uh
at this position after 96 so Rook F6 but
here once again this is not very
intuitive but He suggests that this is
this move is completely winning but
why because after B takes C5 look at
this King and so what computer suggests
and I love this move that's why I love
chess I have Goosebumps this king of two
you take this square away you know and
you're not being made yes of course
you're threatening a mate so like I love
winning moves that are King moves yeah
yes you have to buy King of five here
and
why I like desperation because he
continues with the Rook D5 right and
after King E6 of course you can take a
lot of pounds which check and I think
that you are winning
here he makes another move king of three
it's like this improving your king
position just ignore and everything and
saying that I will take those pawns I
have time but this March king of two
King give three and showing that how um
difficult Black's position is wow so
even though if you are not mates and
then
okay so let's have a quick review for
those of you who made joining us who may
be joining us light shame on you we have
a uh one result one result a big win by
Mama Jada against
uh at the London uh
wrong move uh move order yeah cost a
piece for Bella but we think all four
games at this moment could be kind of
decisive things have changed a little
bit uh since we last looked for example
in the game Anna against Nana it looks
like an equal little Kent game now okay
we left it with the move eighth four oh
oh by the way uh Queen trade did occur
and for Anna that is a great relief
indeed and you're right once that Queen
trade occurred I think the worst is over
and ever and actually uh
yes exactly the King again because this
Pawn is on A4 perhaps on A5 it is more
flexible uh Anna will breathe a sigh of
relief also I think Arena
uh may have fritted away a major part of
her Vantage Bishop H1 Knight D5 Rook G5
Bishop H3
wow okay she captured on H3 captured and
then
voluntarily went into this position was
she putting
I think she must be thinking that her
Bishop
is going to be capturing this Pawn on H2
and
she will have the better of her you know
like you could go check let's let's just
put some moves on the board for just a
second you you can't capture F6 at any
moment because there is a check right
but just the fact that you're so
passive there I I wouldn't think that
this is
I think Irena still has good chances
because white Bishop is really bad on H3
true and black spawn on H4 could be a
good uh pass Pawn right and they're in
time trouble right they're on move 34.
okay 37. okay so they only have three
moves left till till time control and
the times of the players uh minute and a
half against two and a half
minute and a half against women by the
way Arena played the superior I I chose
Bishop C1 I think she played the
superior Bishop C7
and after Bishop C7 Rook D2 on the board
um I don't know I I agree with you the
bishop on H3 is is terrible but is it
enough for black to convert this yeah I
think this is still very very hard uh
like Advantage black yeah I get that but
I don't know Bishops of opposite colors
uh we have a move on the board between
B5 check force in C3 otherwise yeah
check made it yeah I think black has one
good idea after C3 if it works can I
play A5 and B4 very quickly well you can
play A5 certainly I'll get out of Dodge
I will avoid you you want to come down
and maybe tickle me uh what's going on
yeah but she played King C7 she didn't
try A5
uh yeah she probably said okay your sole
source of counter play is based upon
Rook D7 let me I always like that
cutting out my opponent's uh options of
counter play Move Like King C7 I
personally find that move very
attractive she did she played it King C7
again uh the close to the time
controller yes they have one move left
one move left
um
the engines do they they like black did
the evaluation is small or big or tell
Miss well it's for me for me it's not
much it's a 0.3 right now so it's very
close to a draw but let me show you a
position where actually Jean Sayer could
grab a small Advantage yes I think Arena
made a very important mistake well when
she played Rook G5 here so that's the
position which was on the board and
jeans I missed simply missed the chance
just to take on C7
King C7 and to give this check okay
because you know that's uh you know
proof let's say King B7 because King D7
uh doesn't look uh good to me and then
you simply defend the spawn and actually
this bishop is much better the spawn is
attacked and your Rooks are quite active
you know I think that's what's well it's
maybe a slight Edge 0.1 or even equal
but you know white is not risking
anything here gotcha gotcha speaking of
Rook Endings by the way I'm seeing that
uh Elizabeth have fought her way back to
a pawn down Rook ending
um where she seems quite okay yeah this
is where when you see these let me just
put a move on the board when you see
these Rook endings where the Rook ends
up behind and therefore an active Rook
it's very very hard for white to win
oftentimes white ends up running as king
escorting escorting the pawn and that's
going to cost you one or two of your
kingside pawns and maybe you end up uh
drawing so harika
um
letting our opponent maybe off the hook
I didn't see it earlier just picking up
the current position and let me and
they've made time control I think we
should jump to costume because okay
big big very close to me oh my gosh
in two moves Checkmate in two there it
is Knight F4
oh the the king walked the plank
and well
wow
it's over and
wow uh a big big clash between our top
seeds in round one is ended in the
decisive uh victory for Alexandra and
good choices yes sir and Almira well
it's insightful it's it's experience
it's based on intuition all the things
that make a great chess player I want it
to draw your attention to Alexandra's
look after the game you know it's like I
don't want you know to be in front of
her another side of the board right but
as I was about to say this was a very
impressive game from start to finish the
the opening preparation that her novelty
the way she handled her business
pretty impressive the way you say I
would play it opponent with h4h6 all the
way then Rook D1 I loved it wow
beautiful play so two decisive games out
of five we think that Elizabeth is
fighting her way back to an evenish game
Nana oh whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa just a
second she's just played the move King
E5
wow well I mean I just saw one Checkmate
appear on the board of like okay can I
have another Well Imagine This
oops uh that wouldn't be good would it
uh so they've made time control as well
they've made time control so I would be
as white I I would want to stop
any uh intrusions and I don't
are the tables turning here can I play
rookie six
trying to exchange one pair of Rooks
yes sorry I I I I I
58 yeah I'm in some fantasy land where
I'm trying to get my king to B4 or I
don't even know if I could get my king
to E3
um
I have okay yeah no I guess rookie six
and sorry uh Nasi you were about to tell
me that Rook d8 keeping the tension I
thought so
I'll be king F6 and fix the king
situation exactly and just to remind
everybody where we stand at this exact
moment we have two results two wins by
white pieces with Costa nuke and Mama
Zara very impressive uh and uh we're
thinking that the game of arena is more
or less quite balanced we think the game
of Anna and Nana is pretty balanced and
so what did harika actually lose on
their advantage well those trades
beginning with that can help us yeah
well beginning with that move Knight H5
that was a wise decision and I'll never
take it away where did harika let things
slip well actually I wanted to show you
a very important a critical moment in
the Rook end game because I know myself
that they're so difficult to understand
and here actually after King F6 F4 you
had to create a lot of weaknesses in
Black's position and I think that after
four white has a huge Advantage because
now that you take on the four you take
on H5 and this Pawn is also within your
reach and this is a weakness and so I
think that after F4 white is completely
winning so let's say King G6 right Rook
C5 and then what defense do you have
here
the only way of course you can try an
active defense but here no no no
first yes I want to bring my my king
closer and then let's say King F5 I will
try King F2 so King E4 you will not
allow me to play
um King F3 but then I think that they
can even try H4 here so you cannot stop
everything at the same time right so
this position I think is completely
winning for white you still have to be
precise but F4 here was a very important
inclusion
and now that Elizabeth has this Pawn
chain F6 G5 H4 it looks very solid and
she can hold this I think yeah okay
um but uh the The Rook ending
um Amira notwithstanding The Rook ending
uh somewhere in the middle game we were
really we were really happy with the
herika's middle game but the very fact
that Elizabeth was able to fight her way
to a rook ending means we think that
that that Erika missed something along
the way well I I uh let's say I analyzed
the position but at some point harika
has had to win a pound so she yeah she
took on D6 and then she traded queens
and uh then harika made the mistake in
the end game I understand that you have
a very special guest with yourself and
and the studio coming up as we get her
all miked up Almira over to you
a chance to powder his nose welcome
Alexandra congratulations with uh what a
victory first of all uh please tell me a
little bit about your preparation
especially the depths of your
preparation how far did you know the
position and the plans
well I mean I might be mistaken but I
think hampi never played Knight F6 uh at
all I mean she preferred the Italian
and D5 it's out of curiosity this
morning I asked myself well I knew that
there is such a light and I started
analyzing it you know I always blame
myself because at some point I start
analyzing lights lines that
should never I mean happen in the game
but I spent so much time and then I
don't have time for like the main lines
and that's what happened today but
apparently I mean everyone seems to try
to surprise me I mean that started in
Nicosia I couldn't guess a single line
but here I was just lucky very lucky
because this morning I just you know
decided to like um
uh watch this line just yeah and I uh I
didn't of course have time to like
analyze it very deeply but I saw that
it's a very pleasant and game so Bishop
B3 now yeah here it's like seems to be
um
like a trendy move uh because Bishop B5
was played in the game between widget
was playing Lucky I think ESPN Cavite
and even though Andrea won black was
fine after the opening so Bishop B3 uh
isipenka played then after this game in
some World Blitz I think and
um I think he didn't capture B6 so
that's the line goes it's quite forced
uh Bishop C5 yes here and I think he
played
um Bishop F4 or something like this or
at least I might be mistaken but Bishop
takes B6 that's what I was planning to
play no that was another game I'm
talking about the game yesterday
in the world Blitz maybe it's not uh so
this is a novel to Bishop B6 and is this
a new uh concept well maybe I mean again
I haven't analyzed it deeply I just saw
that the engine gives a small plus and
has said to myself okay it's such such a
pleasant end game you know you're not
really at risk of anything and you can
just play for two results which is very
very nice and it's the first game it's
still jet lag so and
um I mean I've had so much trouble with
my wide games in Nicosia just a week ago
so play it safe was white I mean I like
this idea and I was very happy about the
outcome of the opening
um but then yeah but then I was not sure
about 94. I mean I thought maybe I
should have played Knight F1 with the
same idea because it seems that she has
to play Rook uh E8 and then I can play
Knight G3 transposing to the game
because uh yeah after Knight E4 she
could have taken on e4 and then Rook
takes E4 and a rook E8
h2e8
yeah and even though I can take only
eight she has to take with the King
because of Bishop A4 but it's so I mean
rookie one king D7 I mean it's so close
to this opposite colored Bishop even
yeah I was looking at Bishop D5 during
the game because she was thinking for a
very long time but okay Rook a seven and
of course it's a very very pleasant end
game for uh wide but is it like uh
winning I was not sure and I was a
little bit I mean mad at myself that I
didn't play Knight F1 and I was very
relieved when she played Rook h28 so we
kind of transposed to this uh Knight G3
Bishop G6 position this is such a lovely
positional idea three it's four H5 yeah
yeah H4 and I was sure that she was
going to play H5
and I was not sure what to do here
because I was thinking about taking on
E8 and playing Rook D1 but still I
thought that she must play H5 okay and
let's have a look at the end of the game
where like very nice yes it was uh well
study like and I know how much you like
the status so let's have a look uh where
that's like it started I don't know and
then here yes yeah and I think Bishop C5
was a very important mistake well when I
played C3 I mean I a sold this line and
I thought that Bishop C5 should not be
possible of course I didn't see why but
somehow you know this little
um like domination and all those
tactical motifs they just I mean
well you just have this feeling that it
shouldn't work you should be winning but
since time travel was approaching I
repeated the moves yes where you
hesitating here the did you were you
choosing between the move Bishop E6
after Knight A7 let's say uh Bishop B6
no I didn't see I didn't consider Bishop
six so you were always calculating
before no A4 as well instead of Bishop
A4 I mean when I was going to this
position I thought that A4 also seems to
be very nice but I didn't say anything
after Bishop F7 and
um even though I mean my position seems
to be very nice but it's not like a
fourth line anymore and in the game I
mean I thought that she has to play 94
uh King to G6 and 84 King 36 but then I
F5 exactly Bishop takes D4 I capture on
G6 Rook F2
uh King GH3
right yeah King E5 and I take on D4
or I played G7 on King D5 or uh okay
well yeah but you can play King C5 or
king or whatever and I thought that I
can always capture on D4 and play G7 and
I was so happy that I saw this line and
I said to myself okay it should be
winning but then she played Knight D5 a
king D5 she surprised me but again it
just have this feeling that the king is
okay you have to activate your kink in
the end game but this not this sorry
position this is such a beautiful
position Alexandra uh we don't have much
time today I still have one more
question for you which was actually
important because you won so many
tournaments and I think what touched me
the most after uh you won the World Cup
you said that this Victory doesn't have
exactly the same flavor as when I won
the World Championship when I was
younger so could you explain this well
when you get older I mean you don't have
such an energy anymore you don't have
such a motivation anymore I mean you you
lack many things of course you're like
getting experience with every but you
know this experience you just forget
lines and forget your own gifts it's
just been too too many and it's like
every new tournament I mean every New
Year it's it's already quite an
achievement because you kind of force
yourself to go on and to work to fight
to like I mean stand up after uh defeats
but victories or they are so sweet at
this point because you don't I mean you
don't play for Victors anymore you just
play you know to go on to continue to
enjoy the game to create some
masterpieces once in a while and if you
happen to win and it's such a relief and
it's such a pleasure you can never
compare like a victory when you're
almost 40 and victory when you I do and
you're just supposed to win and here you
know that anything can happen so it's
well well it's a masterpiece indeed
thank you Alexandra well uh
well we wish you a lot of luck for the
tournament and well to savor the victory
you know tonight thank you thank you so
congratulations as well uh Alexandria a
very important Victory a beautiful way
of starting the event I wanted to point
out that when we saw their head to head
Alexander hasn't yet defeated Corner
before In classical and this is her
first huge Victory it's very very very
nice and our standings uh at this moment
uh in round one of the Karen's cup so we
had two wins Alexandra Carson and gunai
mamasada won their games
and they're currently the leaders of the
children it goes hand in love yes indeed
and of our remaining games we're seeing
I want to say a lot of even positions we
think that Elizabeth in this Rook ending
um has really fought herself well and
probably is a favorite to uh draw by the
way G4 is a bit of a challenge I would
find myself playing on passant in an
instant myself but also you know just a
little bit pause because the move G4 amp
is on does somewhat allow white the
possibility of an outside pass pawns but
yeah I would be capturing that upon and
then I wanted to say another again game
yeah but this one is a little bit weird
because I could go into a king and
pawning game I always feel like
Who Came Upon end games the bridges are
burned you know that there's no there's
no coming back if you're in a losing
King and pawning game you're lost yeah
there's just no other way so you just
have to make sure that this King and
pawn end game and do you do you count
some crazy race or do you say I will I
will match you move by move yeah I will
match you on the King on the queen side
I don't have any Tempo by the way I
can't I can't neither side has any yeah
I can't gift the move to Black and say
please make a move here or something so
you you have to be careful but we think
that the game is uh in drawing territory
again this is Anna satonski's game and
then finally the arena Crush game I want
to say that even though this is Bishops
of opposite color I really like the fact
that Arena has managed to make White's
King extremely passive on won the first
rank so that just means you're never
going to worry about the Rook because
oops that's going to cost you and in the
meanwhile Black's King I don't know
exactly how but can activate uh so I'm
thinking try but oh for sure she's gonna
try but I'm thinking Arena's uh
definitely on two results for sure
looking at this game and that's already
a victory your insights to this uh
ending Almera yes I'm trying to analyze
it a little bit you were absolutely
right
well white pieces are incredibly passive
and the position of white king is
well a bit so awkward compared you know
to his
homologous
variable yes I was searching for a
French for it let's say I tried King D6
because but then your pieces once again
are optimal squares you need to bring
your king so let's say here after King
B1 King D6 we had this move on the board
while you were talking they were just
sorry I was analyzing the right move
because I thought that this is a very
nice try you you want to bring your king
closer to the action but then maybe C4 a
very human try and John Sayer just made
that move oh
well I still have it
and then how to react here so Bishop C4
a b takes C4 and then
um I don't know why because of course I
was looking at Bishop C4 but then well
the H3 pound is hanging and I well I was
thinking okay what to do here the
computer suggest a very unusual move B4
here and I was trying to understand it
okay uh why because he's trying to
create the past part and you know so he
he is trying to say that while your
pieces are here I will create the past
one and then okay this will be sort of a
balance but now if I will try King E5
you know that's Bishop C4 he says here
so Rook H3 and actually after Rook H3
computer considers that this is already
a draw after Bishop A6 so you have to be
careful you know let's say we will try
to make progress Rook H1 King C2 you
cannot play H3 because the bishop is
hanging so you have to improve
your Rook to play Rook G1 in order to
play H3 but here you have this simple
move and this is a draw you know so
that's your protection because if you're
trying to avoid this then my king is
getting even closer so you have to be
careful
it's like a race between each one and
the Queensland but now remember that
they have this very important resource I
will always play Bishop B7 and you know
the H1 squared the promotion square is
kept well kept yes so uh it's not very
clear to me so how weird well to find
winning chances here so I now I
understand you know the idea behind B4
and it's very interesting from the start
where we do have the position with C4 on
the board first of all I find the move
B4 itself uh kind of a stunning move
takes on C4 B4 you tried King E5 and a
loud Bishop takes C4 right away King D5
would at least have provoked Rook to C3
uh so it's going to cost you some time
yes right let's try King D5 you're
absolutely right I can try Rook C3 okay
and then let's say what do you do here
are you going for the pump okay
each one Rook C1 and beware that now
I've written enough winning Euros okay
E5 or King D4
I didn't want to allow Roxy for a check
and then back Roxy one but then I think
that we're going to get the same
position so after King E5 I will take on
C4 and then Rook H3 and we have seen the
same defensive motive so we'll take on
A6 I will bring my Bishop on B7 and uh
well this is pretty much the defensive
mechanism the the same similar uh kind
of transposing into the same ending
okay close close for arena but uh maybe
just not enough and I was defending
quite well and Anna and uh is really
thinking about this upon ending or
single Rook ending uh another try if I
can for Anna for just a moment we have
this position on has been thinking I'm
going to ask you about the times in just
a moment so I take take and I'm thinking
to myself okay if I can get my king to
before I'll keep your rook in a passive
position
um what do you think am I am I barking
up a tree that's not there I think it's
a nice try but I don't know if there
should be enough it's not enough huh
yeah well and they did Richmond 40 so
now they're playing with the second time
control okay however Anna's been
thinking for a while and she's down to
15 minutes only 30 minutes on the second
time control everybody 30 minutes and
then that's it no more time thereafter
though the players will be playing on
their bonus which is 30 seconds for each
completed move she's going to go for
Rook d8 probably well I suspect that
Anna is a time travel junkie yes simple
let's just put it simple explanation
yeah tell the truth there you go by the
way uh the way she held her hand over uh
her Rook indicated to me she was going
to play Rook d8 if you're going to make
a capture you're doing it the other way
you're doing it so it's like she's
looking to go here as opposed to
sideways the only chess players would
notice yeah yeah and I I'm very very
aware of that in the old days what was
very interesting is the Players would
write down their moves they'd write down
their moves they do a double check and
then they play them but you had some
very interesting players I won't mention
any names who wrote down blunders
who wrote down you know like
uh Bishop C5 as Canary so you'd look
over and you see Bishop CSI you'd be
like oh please play the move Bishop C5
that's a terrible move and then they
play The Right Move
so then yes they purposely put you on
this emotional roller coaster that
they're gonna blunder and then they
never blundered so now I think there's a
rule feeder rule you can't write down
you can't write down a move before you
make it that's right is that why
I don't know why they changed the rule
that I think they thought that was
taking notes but if you read some old
manuals uh play like a grand master it
would tell you write down your move in
advance and now you're and then yeah
but you can't do it anymore there you go
so uh let's just jump to the game of
Elizabeth and I wanted to ask you both
forgetting about the chess engine for a
moment you've got this game of uh harika
and Elizabeth you see the pawn
structures three verses 3 2 verses one
you see the move G2 G4 and is your
instinct to play ampicon right away or
you stop if I have time I will
definitely consider not taken you will
what why because I am changing Pawn
structure once I take white might get
another pass bun on the king side the
outside so that's why I would consider
other options can I just passively
defend this and not change the pawn
structure right but if I was in time
trouble then automatically I would take
on G3 exactly uh Amira your your
instincts the same as nasi's on this one
well actually I would never take one you
would never take wow you don't want to
change the pawn structure at all and not
only that it's not about the pond
structure it's actually about this
important passer and this weakness so I
would think that when the pound was on
G2 what does it actually change the
position nothing so when the the pawn is
on G4 this weakness appears on the
boards so I would think I would like to
keep it there because when a white will
make progress let's say I don't know
play
um after G4 let's say I will stay on you
will make some progress it doesn't
matter I'm just making a few moves so
you'll bring your king then my only hope
is actually to create some counter play
and I I will try to to attack the spawn
in some way so let's say you will go I
don't know okay I'm trying to maneuver
and then if you go here for example
you'll try to bring the king closer so I
will try to create some sort of counter
play playing Rook C1 Rook H1 next and of
course you can defend your opponents by
playing rookie 3 but I I would keep an
eye on this phone because I think that's
taken on G3
it's counter-intuitive here let's say in
this position so G4 but actually
computer proves us wrong and he wants to
take on G3 he thinks that this position
is actually easier to defend but well I
know how difficult it is because
whenever I am a pound down I'm always
losing an end game and when I'm a power
enough I'm always drawing
I probably have to study a few of those
in either box book I understand you
completely it's it was terrible in my uh
professional career When I Was preparing
for the games as white I never found
advantages and as black I was always
slightly worse
it was just not fair you know you're
upon up you're not winning it's a draw
you're Pawn down you're it's lost it's
gone it's terrible all right that's uh
that's interesting I would be playing
hthg3 ampasan automatically and again I
want to go to Arena game because I had
to conceitful with the bishop I think
we're looking at B4 though
yeah that that's a difficult human move
I would say just for sure like that and
she did get in the the A6 A5 and that
avoids what Almira was showing us those
two pawns versus the H Pawn now if you
want to play B4 okay you've got a
password I I don't question now yes sir
would you take on F7 or would you go
Bishop F1 oh gosh I would never even
think about taking on F7 because I would
be so afraid that my Bishop not only
yeah not only too far I I mean it's like
the F5 Pawn is not going anywhere in the
H3 Pawn the H4 Pawn blacks H4 pawn and
by the way she didn't she in fact she
she she set up a situation where she
can't play Bishop F1 anymore she played
Rook D3 check so for example after a
move like King C7 oops you're not
doing any you you can't defend the pawn
you're almost obliged to play Bishop
takes and Bishop D5 I'm also curious
after Rook D3 check yeah like Irina just
played what if King E5 which is on the
board allowing Rook D5 check then going
forward let's say King E4 right okay
five and Rook H3 again it's a race but
now white pieces feel so far away from
the h-bone yes to begin with and but
even worse to your point I'm thinking
there's even checkmating possibilities
like if you start looking at checks and
checks and putting the bishop on E5 the
king ever got to see three I'm seeing
tons of mating patterns so King E5 Rook
D5 check
King E4
you almost like to go on the dark
squares you know King F4 but okay King
E4 just want to keep the king closer to
D4 C3 exactly this whole complex where
you you doing this I would be very very
afraid uh probably the engines are
saying yeah and all of that good stuff
but as a human player I'm sitting there
going I can see
easy easy how I'm going to lose you know
like how am I going to force a draw I
don't see any clear pathway to forcing a
draw so I think that that the arena is
feeling confident even though she has no
idea what the the chess engines are
evaluated and I'll mirror just jump in
how are the chess engines about I'm
seeing two results but maybe I'm way off
the mark
oh not really so that's the moment where
I was falling asleep welcome to Jeff yes
I was thinking that Irina has a huge
advantage over John Sai because I think
you know she had a good night's sleep
and then so let's have a look at this
position after Rook G3 yeah so uh the
king E5 is already on the board because
I I say didn't get the moves
um
King E5 so you were analyzing uh yes and
yes uh computer was considering both
possibilities uh playing King E4 Bishop
E5 but it's always oscillating between
0.9 and 1 which means that white still
has a lot of defensive resources and
please don't forget that if the words
come to the worst then you can sacrifice
your Bishop over like all of the pounds
if you have a chance and then it will
come to the end game where you will have
to defend with your Rook against rook
and the Bishops so we know that this is
a theoretical draw but a lot of things
may happen on the way
so that's why computer is evaluating
this position only as a slightly better
for for black and here for example after
King E5 uh He suggests for white B4 Rook
D5 check has been played giveaway but he
he was suggesting playing before right
okay creates in the past found
immediately because you're going to lose
one of those pounds anyway so let's say
Rook H3 and once again it's very
important to put the bishop on the big
diagonal it's very important like to
keep the H1 Square so even if for
example let's let's see if you try to
take to grab the pan now another very
important move just you have to bring
your king
so yes in the game and so this is close
to a draw according to the computer wow
I noticed that you said big diagonal as
opposed to a long diagonal so uh in you
know our chess parlance in English the
long diagonal is well A1 to h8 or H1 but
you say big diagonal yes
okay so not as big as Advantage as I
assume but now that we have Rook D5
check and not B4 on the board and we're
assuming King E4 which is on the board
which is on the board uh break this down
is this a big difference compared to the
lines that you were just proposing
well actually computer
computer advantage
is getting a bit bigger so uh taking a
forward D5 now he actually suggests Rook
D3 back which is not going to be played
you do not play Rook D through Rook D5
check with the idea of coming back you
do it with the idea of taking the pawn
so let's have a look at this ratio okay
five Rook H3 exactly exactly so once
again Bishop D5 crucial yes crucial King
D4 it looks scary for white or D3 let's
try King D3 because I think that's uh
this is the checkmating threats we're
hoping to achieve yes this is a very
important way uh that black has to
create a mate in that but then okay four
he's the well he has no emotions so he's
trying to defend and after Bishop E5 He
suggests that you should defend with
Rook G4 and that's how you well you
protect yourself from the checks because
you don't have Rook H1 whatever I play
Rook H2 then you he wants to play Rook
jitu I think
I don't know
yes that's what I'm seeing that's yes
I'm starting to fall asleep
good morning St Louis yes okay then Rook
H2 let me have a look with a human eye
because what what are you threatening on
Rugby I guess not H3 H3 I just want to
play Rook H3 Rook B2 checking I also had
an idea to go Rook B2 check King C1 and
Rook A2 okay let's try A4 but I want to
keep my H Pawn H3 let's let's try H3
let's go and now Rook H4 yes of course
I'm trying to guard the okay let's
question
yeah I also have Rook a2s here
[Music]
okay that was just a lucky shot
Grandmama
oh boy okay but do we have Rook D5 check
on the board by The Rook takes eight no
King E4 we don't have Rook A5
is seeing something that she's not happy
about so let's have another look maybe
she's trying to understand if there is a
way for her to defend you know after
King F4 King D3 because this is a very
important defensive resource if you
don't see it then you don't go for The
Rook D5 or K5 exactly okay so let's
start again Rook takes A5 and a lot of
sometimes maybe this Pawn on F5 is
crucial I don't know let's start with
Bishop E5 we know that we're going to
need to move our Bishop one day so let's
start with Bishop E5 I will go Bishop D5
anyway because we know that yeah
so now I have a passer now my King's in
the way now you'll have two passers okay
I hope I hope yeah okay let me try
Bishop C6 first okay so that's the cool
way for me to protect against indirectly
defends upon and I need to get my king
out of the way anyway so King F4 so I'm
prepping uh I could go check by the way
I could go check and picking up Pond
grabbing and you know that's my favorite
sport but King F4 oh no Rook okay
oh no then I have to go King G5 that's
not what I wanted why can't you go can
you oh thanks H4 hangs well let's try
because it's uh it's a valid idea I
think but they I feel that this is not
enough let's say F5 yeah that was
probably your idea absolutely I wanted
to pass F Pawn so and uh your king is
still on B1 and it's not participating
in the battle so let's say well I will
try to attack the pawn and F5
and if you push F4 maybe bishop is
hanging yes the bishop is hanging yes so
let's try a check right and do something
like this no
okay Rook F2 yeah but well I feel that
after A4 we have few moves on the board
we definitely have a number between say
I took on F7 well she started the Rook
takes A5 as expected after Rook takes A5
Rook takes H3 by Arena that was clear
ly her plan all along
but this move Bishop takes F7 this would
really frighten me
uh because I would be afraid of The Rook
checking and Rook H2 so because the H
Pawn is suddenly Unleashed like uh let's
say Rook check King C2 Rook
um check and I'm thinking you can't go
up much like I was going to get checked
from behind and lose my Rook I'm walking
into a shish Kaba
don't wanna I don't want to Shish Kebab
so I'm forcing the king to back
backtrack and now whether I play Bishop
E5 or the more
prosaic H3 maybe even Rook D2 you know
what I'm warming to Rook D2 Rook D2 is
nice not allowing yeah Bishop D5 at all
and I'm sensing opportunity here for
arena uh Almera uh I don't like the
combination of Rook A5 and Bishop F7 I
didn't think that was good
um just a second I'm trying to get the
life position on the board so after
Bishop Ace F7 no we have Rook D5 check
first Rook D5 check first king E4 take
the pawn take the pawn
yeah so this is the position
let me uh just have you can switch to a
different game and then come back okay
there you go okay so oh yes this section
computer says that this this was a huge
blunder that after Bishop F7 it
evaluates it's at minus more than minus
two yeah so that's a surprise yeah so
let's have a look so Bishop F7 Rook H1
you mentioned this move the king C2 Rook
H2 yep okay but then the King was
already on B1 so then um but the Rook
was on H3 standing in front of the pawn
so now after King B1 I think which is
and this is where Nasi was saying Rook
D2 no you should be fine well no you you
were approving you were approving you
gave me the confidence I needed we're
thinking instead of Bishop E5 we're
thinking Rook David two yes stopping
Bishop D5 this is for good that's a very
nice move but let's say I'm try I will
try to use the same difference if they
say the same defensive idea we'll try to
play Bishop B8 and Bishop C6 check I I
need to stop this pound you will
probably end up playing
either way yes but I think that black is
winning right now so now if white goes
are okay for and takes the pawn there's
just Checkmate no we have okay
yeah I think yes another is suggesting
uh rookie four so after Bishop D4
the difference between the Bishops is is
is enormous in uh on your board and
let's try Bishop C6 and here you can go
actually King G3 yeah yeah and it's
looking really really good for arena as
we're gonna take a break just reminding
everybody where we stand in this the
first round of the Cairns cup we have
two results both the decisive both in in
White's favor and Alexandra wow Dominate
and win wow and that checkmating pattern
at the end uh that look it up uh people
that was really really good stuff two
draws expected but maybe arena is going
to be our third win and our first win
with the black pieces we're gonna see
you on the other side of the break we'll
be back shortly
thank you
the St Louis chess club is the Premier
chess facility in the United States we
bring the educational benefits of Chess
to thousands of students across the St
Louis area we also promote Chess at the
highest levels hosting all levels of the
U.S championships as well as
high-profile tournaments that attract
the world's best players become a member
and enjoy perks such as free classes and
lectures weekly tournaments and so much
more visit
stlouischessclub.org to claim your
membership today
the World Chess Hall of Fame located in
the heart of St Louis's historic Central
West End want to know why Jess has
intrigued people around the world for
nearly 1500 years stop by and learn
about the impact of Chess from our three
floors showcasing the art culture and
history of the game the World Chess Hall
of Fame has something for everyone to
enjoy for more information on current
exhibits please visit worldchess hof.org
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
welcome back everyone and this is our
result so far we have two wins by white
pieces Carson yuk and Mama's Adam
yeah and in the three remaining games
we're anticipating two draws but on the
bottom table on table five it looks like
Arena crash has managed to turn a
bishops of opposite color ending to a
win and
and we've got a cardinal St Louis
Cardinals Fan very nice you look very
good in the baseball cap well I remember
that I had it with me and actually I
wanted to tell you that uh at my first
baseball game when we went to it was the
Cardinals game at the stadium in San
Luis we were invited on the field with
the world champion Magnus Carlson says
like a lot of people were jealous so go
cards and also and was that the one
where he threw out the first pitch
exactly okay did he make it to home
plate did he throw it to the catcher
well he didn't make it yes on the first
bounce
only after the first let's jump into the
game of Arena crash
oops uh
as we finish up day one a little
reminder of our schedule we're finishing
up round one tomorrow players will play
round two and on June 8th they will have
a rest day exactly and all the games
will be on the same schedule uh of play
that was uh one o'clock
um St Louis time
and arima has just played the move king
after Bishop C6 King on e4 to D3 boy I
tell you I would have a lot of trouble
there my hand you know would be you know
reaching with that F5 Pawn but she did
play the move King D3 and she did
purposefully because she's setting up
these check mating Nets like you can
easily imagine okay right now of course
we understand that but if we get a check
and a check on A1
um let me just make a bad move sorry A4
Rook I'm just going to play two bad
moves and this is the Checkmate arena is
looking to achieve very very nice and
the King on D3 covers the C2 square and
if Rook D5 check I think her idea is to
just play Bishop D4 yep
maintaining now threading location and
now threatening uh you know hold on are
we sure about that because King C3 is
also attractive isn't it
you know uh again that but yeah I think
you're right Bishop D4 no I I think
that's it it's time a factor uh Irina
has 10 minutes has 11 minutes so not
really not yet but uh
is that you're beginning to feel it yes
if there were in real time trouble I
think every now we just win this game in
few moves right but right now ashantaya
still has time to figure things out but
actually defend this position or is it
completely lost well I think that black
is completely winning and I actually
tried a very simple idea after Rook E5
so then Bishop C6 King D3
um well let's say I will play Bishop B7
here okay and I will keep the same
position so I think that you know well
this is of course protected but then
maybe he can simply play Rook G2 it's a
very human move you know and I'm still
threatening in Rook G1 and rookie one
made right so I don't see that what can
you do here let's say you you'll play
before because you we will have to
escape yay too so uh Rook G1 maybe King
E2 and then H2 right and you're winning
what is the most important that you kept
the F6 pounds so that's sufficient for
the win exactly uh just being told that
Anna zatonski is in time travel that's a
little bit and
she has been trying to achieve something
she's been trying to squeeze uh uh blood
from Stone in this ending and after the
move Rook E5 now the board is
would be a huge mistake is it let's take
a look what king is much faster and I
think going down and gobbling the pawn
yes King F4 King G3 and black winds yeah
one of the things that I actually
really beautifully Charmed me and please
uh to the audience the pawn
breakthroughs I mean are so nice there
are so many beautiful studies where well
you know you sacrifice two three pawns
to get these breakthroughs uh so Rook E5
Rook G4 okay this is this kind of a
stream yeah but it's a it's peculiar
that you're allowing
black to have
you know back here when we were I
thought that Anna was doing everything
to keep her or her wedding hopes alive
like
wow she could have like just taken this
Rook Perpetual at some point too exactly
and the current position
well Amira is it just zeros or
the advantage seems to be shifting a
little bit
uh well let's have a look at the
position after Rook G4 mm-hmm
sorry because I was trying to analyze if
there is a possibility for white to do
something we have rookie too also yes
and by the way King C1 that's a clear
indication
that uh
uh a draw right
that is to say Anna is happy at this
point to settle for a draw yes but I
think that the idea behind the move
rookie too is that after King's one you
will try
at least for one more if you will play
Rook F2 so what if white just stands and
goes King B1 yes exactly you need to
wait you need to wait you need to play
King B1 let's say I will try to do the
same I will play King F5 and then you
simply go King C1 again okay yes and
this is the way to hold this position
but okay let's see if you have another
we have King F5 on the board not Rook F2
but King F5 immediately by Nana
and right here King F5 oops excuse me
and
King F5 no F4
King B1 very good
yeah black looks better for sure their
Rook is more active King is better even
Pawn structure he could argue is better
but how the Breakthrough is yeah no no
no breakthroughs at this moment
um
uh Elizabeth uh we thought that she's uh
well she was suffering I think she's now
very happy about her decision to play
the move H takes G3 because that wasn't
even mad henrica didn't even play F
takes G3 a bit of a surprise I think for
us uh Nasi was Rook takes G3 and it's
very I must say it's very very rare that
you ever want to
um split your own your own pawns that
was uh and I think Elizabeth was rather
happy to see that decision and they
quickly well they've reached a position
where black has an active Rook active
King and again we're going to turn to
Arena's game because she's actually got
an issue right here Rook check on D5 I I
like the move Bishop D4 a lot but I can
understand if other players find the
move King C3 pretty attractive and again
it's 10 minutes to 10 minutes
and she has played Bishop D4 she has
played Bishop D4 oh
Uranus down to eight minutes eight they
both have eight minutes and she played
Bishop D4 right and I love that move
because first of all made in two is uh
being threatened and furthermore I mean
if you do defend the meat
well I'm still it is it's so close yeah
yeah I have
here I play rugby two check and win your
Bishop
Rook B2 King C1 Rook C2
oh
yeah you're a mean person that that's
really okay
did anybody ever tell you you're mean
yeah oh and fact
that is actually the huge threat to
Simply Rook check and rookie has to
include Bishop B5 check which is
terrible because you want to maintain a
coverage
of the eight bit wait a minute this is a
threat of me so two huge threats in the
position I'll mirror Rook H1 and Rook a
one is Checkmate but also Rook B2 and
Rook C2 wins a piece and
well I think that there's no defense
there's you're you're going to end up I
don't know sacrificing your rook in
exchange in well the F pawns the
presence of the f-pawns
we have we have a move I think what did
she play
Rook D6
Rook D6 okay that defends the bishop
very important
uh it also now maybe Almira suggestion
suggestion Rook G2 is winning
I really like that one you do
uh could I suggest Rook chick you want
to grab a pawn
yeah King C1 Rook check
um King B1 back King B1 back she's going
for it
I guess it I guess it just transposes
I'm sorry I now I'll go back to Rook G2
which were you we we could have started
with and by the way Arena maybe I'm
teleporting
uh picking up uh signals here but uh
rookie two check was on she could take
Pawn on B3 three
excited boy it's just a free Pawn I tell
you she could earn a gold membership
into the pond grubbers club uh with Rook
takes B3 uh
yeah I guess there's a lot of ways of
winning yes and you know it's not just
grabbing the pawn she's threading rookie
three to K1 checkmates
that's also very nice to grabbing
another Pawn as well as setting up a
mating net uh I'm really warming up
Suddenly The Rook takes B3 you know
that's really good I I've been afraid to
ask you Amira really I've been afraid to
ask you but please do tell me that after
the move Bishop C check Bishop C check
Bishop C6 Jack yes sir what's up 54. I
move 54.
I wanted to take the pawn on F5 I really
please tell me that would have also won
the game
after Bishop C6 King D3 which is a very
strong move it's a very strong move
would king takes F5 have worked as well
let's have a look at King takes the five
yes well you're still uh keep well
you're keeping your advantage the
computer evaluates this is plus three
not correct and it's very important of
course to keep the Rook on the uh second
rank so uh well the king is stuck on B1
and you're keeping your mating ideas
good by the way Roxy to check King B1 on
the board in the current position Arena
has a tactical and she can take Rook C6
oh my word Rook take C6 Rook takes C6 H2
H2 but I'm gonna stop you see one and
she's done it oh she she spotted them
she spotted the tactic Rook takes C6
with takes C6
H2 Rook C Bishop G1
nice
that finishes with a flare
wow
what did this what did Almira say a
delicate touch
es
in Portuguese
nice and we do have a handshake and
Arena
uh it's our third the Sicilian winners
our third Victor
uh she's the first time first to win
with the black pieces two games
remaining and well all decisive
the Karen's cup uh brings out
do we say the best or the worst but
we've seen a little bit of the worse
unfortunately Bella uh well jet lag I
think we were going to she was a victim
of China Irina might have a home field
advantage I mean she doesn't live in San
Luis but she is from United States
exactly she's not suffering the jet lag
uh that's uh so many of the competitors
are left we have two Rook end games
and both seem very equal yep I think
Anna Nana's game should end quickly
because I don't see how black can
progress can progress at all yeah Anna
has found this idea to just stand and
move the king to B1 and C1 right do you
find that uh hard to do to be the
patient Defender to just sit there and
go King C1 King B1 no I love it you love
it and I look at my opponent what are
you gonna do
I hate I I mean uh I'm the active
Defender I'm always trying to look for
and sometimes you know just holding the
position it's a skill actually uh and
you don't have to have that patience
yeah and not weaken your own position
but if you enjoy passive defense there's
nothing better you just sit back and
relax let your opponents figure it out
okay yeah and here uh to remind those
who are joining us later our day so far
right we had three wins uh Alexander
castanoke won a beautiful game against
uh hampi conero Mama Zara won a quick
game today against Bella and Irina Crush
I just want a beautiful Sicilian game
against transaya abdomalik yeah very
very nice strategical game from a Rouser
with a lot of great ideas and the break
D5 worked to a charm as we're seeing uh
Anna on the white side just holding I'm
gonna say slightly worse Rook ending but
like you say the where's your
breakthrough Nana has just put a rook on
a e3 I can imagine that okay she could
play for rugby three and C3 is there a
potential there we do have King D2 so if
if Nana is going to try to play for a
win Rook B3
let's say King C2 C3 this is the only
way to upset the apple card and I think
but even here I think I can stand with
King B2 okay
P3 only move in Kingston to back how do
you improve
black Rook is kind of stuck I'm not
going to play A3 and Rook B2 check I'll
hang my Rook you're right there's
nothing there's nothing to say and if
you play let's say waiting wolf King F6
yep then I can I have a yeah I can just
play Rook E4 just wait and move as well
ah you because in this case your king is
actually stuck you right any King moves
would allow this but now you can just
wait with the Rook yes and every time I
play King B2 you go back and you kind of
smile smirk yes
nothing no problemo okay so we do expect
this game to be a draw and in the
Elizabeth
harika harika enjoying an extra Pawn has
just played the move H4
maybe she's trying to put Lisa in time
trouble because we know in time trouble
even in a very draw or can't game you
can still make inaccurate moves easily
easily H4 G5 takes H4 okay I'm not
sure well it's quite active now maybe
there's some chances no I wasn't I
wasn't so sure about that one that one I
would have had
because in some ways I'm kind of happy
to have my Pawn on G5 you know it stops
any F4 but okay G3 takes H4 King takes
H4 give white 16 moves in a row
and I can tell you what she's going to
do she's going to bring her King all the
way across
the fourth rank all the way towards the
B5 pawn and black may have to
[Music]
H4 was inaccurate yeah
it felt like it's wrong you could have
played just rooked you and check
a moment ago right let's say King H2 and
just go back and wait for white to take
on G5 that
felt more because one of the things that
if we just okay pardon me if we look at
it from from this point of view the
white Rook is perfect it defends A3 it
defends F2
on the F3 Square the move G4 can upset
The Rook force it could decide yeah now
and now compared to the game position
and I'm just going to go back and forth
to refresh my board
you don't have to move G4 anymore so I
can
like I say uh sneak my way all across
the board and my Rook remains on F3
this is the way that black could easily
lose the game so I think our plan is if
White NOW plays King G4 which I'd play
She Wants to Play Roxy for a check okay
I'm cutting your King off of the fourth
Rank and if you go Rook F4 I just go
Rook C3
if the white king is cut off then it's
hard to make progress with white okay so
let's just continue
the point you've made oh you have F4
okay
well it doesn't matter I think we're
going to get the same kind of position
um and I'm sure it's simply a table base
yeah but I don't think you're really
ever going to be able to stop me from
playing F4 uh and the table base says
winning win it winning this is winning
this is winning wow because of yeah
right so uh yeah
um
so well
I don't know why it's because yeah
yeah
how about that
um King G3
okay well in some ways that's kind of
the same no I'm sorry it's not King
um sorry Rook C1 not King G4 King G
wow uh okay I'm threatening King F4 but
I'm inviting King G5 maybe she wants to
Rook D3 here threatening Rook defile
with a check okay
Fair
also
I was going to say F4 is also with a
check but that doesn't change things not
so much right
question is should black ever push the F
Pawn F5
I don't know I don't know that's a very
uh it's
you know everything is now becoming very
very concrete and very very specific
let's just imagine I do it right and
then I can figure out how are you going
to make progress here again I'm thinking
that the king can come across but now
your Rook is no longer on the ideal
Square F3 by the way let me just refresh
my board and jump back
King G3 King G5 Rook D3 so let's ask the
Salient question at five and gf3 King F3
okay fair you want to put the Rook on C2
yes
62 King E3
King did you say E3 yes okay
guess Rook A2
um sorry I'm just
I've given myself a pause because I'm
really considering g king G4 very
seriously here okay uh I'll go with Rook
A2 fine
uh I'm keeping I think white has to play
F3 at some point in order to be able to
move the king farther exactly and in
that case I think I want my king cozying
up to the F Pawn so if you play F3 check
then my king will be on G3 and your king
will go to D4 and my king will be let's
say ideal
so yeah I like my king on G4 so you can
give me can I do something
crazy maybe sacrifice the Pongo King D4
Rook F2 King C5 do I have it chance to
win that well if my two pawns go far
enough then I'm happy to sacrifice my
Rook
so is this race
uh
I'm trying to determine whether
uh not counting very maybe we'll be in
the queen end game yeah that's what it
should be a draw right wow uh Almera
Jump Right In something something uh
something oh sorry we're not quite there
yet
um yeah this has suddenly become
intriguing yes yeah and I think it was
because that uh move uh G5 takes H4 gave
harika more possibilities more chances
than if
if Elizabeth had just allowed H4 takes
G5 so
things are getting
interesting we have a winner of this
round said enough for the interview
you're in a crush Victory with the black
pieces she'll be with us in studio very
very shortly
well in fact let's go tell Mira
we have a very special guest in the
studio Arena congratulations first of
all win but with the black pieces before
you unravel the mysteries of your game
today and your preparation please tell
us how do you feel is it an advantage to
play in the home turf
oh well we'll see when the tournament is
over you know
um but in general of course I'm happy to
play in St Louis
um any any kind of tournament whether
it's like a national event or an
International Event
um and yeah of course I don't have to
deal with the jet lag you know that is
always nice right as like someone who's
often like had to go and play in Europe
it's definitely nice to have some events
at home but I think maybe maybe the the
bigger Advantage is just that like how
much I love St Louis you know because
I've been coming here you know since
2009 multiple times a year so I feel
like really comfortable here and I'm
always happy to come back
okay so let's have a look at your game
first of all tell us a little bit about
the opening have were you expecting this
variation and what were the critical
moments yeah I mean I was expecting an
open Sicilian as the most likely
um line so it was kind of like you know
she's quite principled in her opening
choices with white so like the Rouser
variation not a surprise we've had that
they're um in games between ourselves
before so I mean it was only a question
of like you know which let's say Rouser
was I going to pick right and um so I
went for something I've played this line
sometimes in the past
yeah I mean F4 she's played a few times
so like there was nothing really
unexpected like it's just about like you
basically have to agree that you're
gonna play this structure of position
with a double death pawns you know I
mean of course the computer is always
going to give an edge to White
um but what I found in the game I mean
it's like it's a really rich position
and I actually enjoyed playing it
okay so let's have a look so we're not
here yeah it's where the structures
change so you you're forced to take GTX
F6 of course otherwise white is taken on
G6 F5 H5 yeah she's played F5 before
right so like that's also you know just
the most direct move um in this position
and okay I would say that H5 is um it's
an option for black there's a lot of
ways black can play this position so
this was just something that I had like
uh picked out for today you know and uh
well I wanted to come back to this
position and actually I thought that
Queen V6 is a mistake because Jean say
is such a dynamic player so after Queen
V6 the game went your way so what do you
think so look at let me tell you
actually what I thought was the first
critical moments of the game
um so it was okay we can go quickly
through like Queen A5 like after King V1
Queen A5 okay so Queen A5 is like it's a
typical move for these positions right
like pinning the Knight so that she
cannot transfer it from to E2 so you're
like kind of holding off this maneuver
so she played Bishop D3 it's one of the
possible moves I castled queen side Rook
ht1 yeah very natural centralization
King B7 and yeah the reason the king is
going to B7 is to sometimes give the
queen these Queen B6 ideas so Queen F2
Rook C8 and like really my big think in
the game came after she played Knight E2
um because here like okay on one hand
you're thinking okay Knight B4 A3 Knight
takes D3 Rook D3 do you want that
position yeah with the two Bishops
versus the two knights I kind of decided
I didn't yeah I see I see that was
correct at some point I was just like
there's so many
um you know ideas here for white I
basically improved her Rook
um sometimes there's even ideas like
Queen H4 E5 like blowing up the center
so
um so I thought for a long time here and
ultimately I went for this movie E5 and
I was quite happy with this it wasn't
the first move that came to my mind
um but you know normally you're not
supposed to really play this move if the
Knight has access to D5 but here I
realized like if she goes Knight C3
Knight B4 actually seems to work out in
terms of
um tempos you know because Rook takes C3
is coming and yeah let's say three Rook
C3 if she actually takes yeah well she
takes on B4 then Queen B4 kind of holds
everything even after Queen G2 Rook uh
yeah like she can't pin me because
um Queen D2 and Rook hc8 you know and I
I don't lose my Rook basically there's
no way she can win it because even after
King C1 there's like Queen A4 and
there's Checkmate
yeah you know I mean that's what I mean
like there were some cool things
involved and I really felt like this
movie E5 was like really an important
decision right because you're changing
the pawn structure obviously you're also
keeping out the knight from D4 and F4
um so I see the computer is not super
impressed with this move but you know
honestly I felt like it was it was a
decent move and it kind of like that's
where the game started to change you
know
so she went um 90 C1 quite quickly
Queen B6 yeah and I mean she has a big
Choice here I did feel like you said
Queen trade just in general like Not a
Bad Thing against an attacking player
right so
um and I really actually just thought
the end game was was not going to be a
problem for black
so but did she have an option like of
like keeping the questions on the board
yeah Queen D2 I mean
um what was I gonna do here yeah I mean
I didn't have any specific plans to be
honest they can oh like at some point
you can think about about even like well
no okay maybe not before actually Knight
A5 wasn't one idea that there you go now
I remember some of my thoughts Knight A5
yeah and um yeah you know the night can
come to C4 sometimes or even just before
maybe
um maybe play Rook C7 Rook C8
um but yeah it felt kind of normal okay
so Queen B6 so what did you feel here
were you happy after yeah I felt I
didn't think that I should be worse like
I wasn't exactly sure what I was going
to do on Knight E2 but I felt like I was
gonna have a way to keep her night out
of D5
and then that was my next big thing of
the game when I found this bishop d897
which you know again I was quite happy
to see that idea because the Knight on
E7 is doing a good job but the bishop on
C7 is also not so terrible
okay I mean you have to walk us through
through the most important moments of
the game because like we have very
little time because I think they I
wanted to ask you here it was very well
one of the crucial moments of the game
because your opponent sacrificed in
exchange look you didn't take it yeah
what did you think here yeah okay so I
took the night right so it's basically
the question should I take should I I
mean why didn't take it I mean I guess I
was just like you know white takes with
an i plays Bishop D3 Bishop E4 and I was
kind of like afraid that um you know
this there would be some big
compensation here you know but I see I
see there's that I also thought like
I'll probably be able to take the Rook
later which didn't work out yeah no I
mean definitely I knew that this this
moment like I kind of messed it up okay
and then uh well I think it's a human
decision because it's not easy to valid
if well there could be a fortress on the
white squares so let's let's have a look
so
either way just to interrupt you uh uh
Almera for just a second we it looks
like a a repetition has been achieved
between Anna and Nana on the other hand
we think it was an inaccurate claim and
we see the deputy Arbiter there uh Chris
um bird saying no yeah it's not correct
I'm going to give two to two minutes uh
bonus to no she lost two minutes of her
clock no I think the other player gets
uh two minutes yeah you would lose on
time so you you you you don't get uh you
you don't get penalized that your
opponent gets uh two minutes but okay
nonetheless we probably expect the game
to draw sorry for interrupting
um you Almera please back to you and
Arena yes Serena is actually
have a look at this very important
moment where your opponent took an F7
did you have a feeling here that you
were already winning
yeah I mean I guess like it's much
easier to play this position on
intuition for black than for white right
and it's kind of like what I felt was
like she was kind of trying to play on
intuition this end game but the problem
is it's a lot harder to do that as white
you know white has like specific
problems to solve black has very few
things they need to think about except
how to promote the age pawn and like
make mating threats to the white King
right so when she took the pawn it was
like it didn't shock me or anything
because I just felt like she was kind of
in this mode right like she went for the
a pawn she abandoned the age Pawn so I
mean I didn't know like if this was the
big mistake or it had already happened
but like I knew that you know it's going
to be um very uncomfortable for white to
play yes and here you made a few precise
moves so uh okay each one of course yeah
my favorite move was Bishop D4 in the
end you know that was that was one thing
I actually stopped to calculate I don't
know if King C3 is as good Bishop D4 I
was like oh I'm threatening Checkmate
Rook H1 and then I'm also threatening uh
rugby two Rook C2 winning the bishop and
she cannot here's the line that I
calculated I'll actually show you the
nice one
um so let's say she plays like should B5
right Bishop B5 check so I was gonna go
King C3 and okay so I'm threatening
um
well let's say she goes Rook d8 yeah and
so basically I just go Rook H1 King A2
and H2 because now I got her Bishop off
the diagonal and the problem is
um yeah I mean if basically if she's
going Rook h8 then just King C2 is going
to be made and here
um okay yeah here I guess I just moved
my rook and promote okay Irina thank you
very much we have to go see you tomorrow
thank you guys uh congratulations to you
Arena we've got a big game going on here
with lots of back and forth uh of
Elizabeth Elizabeth
given hereka a huge opportunity and it's
sort of like been a hot potato
as uh the players are passing winning
positions to harika and drawing
positions back to Elizabeth what's going
on to be fair Elizabeth has been playing
with just one minute on the clock okay
it's very hard to make it's the only
accurate moves right so in the position
we're analyzing we're discussing F5
which was actually the right move she
went back
right about here 64. yeah and it was
that was this was the moment where F5
was drawing and then since that time
however we we're in some table base and
white is winning why why it was winning
okay it is or was it okay yeah so before
white played rugby six check that was
not a good move yeah here table base was
saying white is winning with move F4
four
don't ask me why I wanted to ask you why
but like get smart I won't ask you and
by the way we
uh they did meet the three the
requirements for a three move petition
not without a penalty though you got a
two minute bonus and our first and only
draw of the round thus far we have three
decisive games and maybe a fourth sorry
uh and and here here are the results
this far right we had three wins uh
question Juke Mama Zara and Crush I have
won their games and we have one drop
between satonski and zadnita I so glad
you did that I mean I was like wow that
third table boy I gotta tell you that's
tough okay back to our sole remaining
game we have f4 on the board currently
so she gave the check first and then for
some reason this is not winning anymore
right and now after Rook p8 hold on let
me just uh refresh my uh Erica has four
minutes and Elizabeth has one minute so
at this moment Rook B8
uh the table base tells us
draw
with the move just a rook B1 Rook B1
just uh holding and waiting
um okay I can imagine that
okay what hold on let me gather my
thoughts and say it in a way
I want to win your rook and I imagine
that it's going to cost me my F Pawn to
do that right so I want to make it as
difficult as possible but as as quickly
as possible I want to win your Rook so
if I go B5 and you give me a check is
that drawn King D5 Rook takes King C5 so
I'm gonna make it difficult for you to
get your Rook back so you go down F1 I
hit you with a hakasito right King H5
and I go excuse me I go B6
F5 F5 B7
and rugby one Rook B1 and so you I win
your Rook but your king is very close
well kinda right
I did not play that well no I understand
you were just being helpful but we're
just trying to demonstrate
how uh things might unwind and by the
way Let me refresh let me push B5 she
played Rook B5 instead she did it's a
strange move
okay and we do have and I heard Barb was
telling us that black could have played
F5
black could have played fi instead of
rookie one check
oh oh even here it looks Rook takes F5
rookies
remarkably losing yeah so F5 check was
an opportunity I think even here black
has a five is that true though just a
second
I yeah yeah I hear you loud and clear on
that one that was siren
one Rook F1
okay sorry I did not play F5 she gave a
check
and she was Erika by the way Captain
King uh uh I'm gonna refresh my board
pardon me as I come back and forth uh
because she stopped because there is
Rook F1 right
F of five it's calculated
uh
it was
wait a minute is it okay so Rook takes
F5 Rook takes F5 oops here and 1955
should be winning King D5 I thought I
was in the Square this exact position is
one of in one of dwaretsky's end game
manuals
and we just heard that there was another
blunder alert Elizabeth was supposed to
play Rook C1 check but now after Rook F1
F5 this is the position we're looking at
it is winning again for white it's back
to yeah like I said the the point is
being tossed back and forth like a hot
potato I'm sorry wow
but if you don't I mean excuse me if you
don't see right here because in your
mind's eye you're calculating B5 King
here B6 King here and you think I've got
this if you don't see King D5
oops and now she she may have seen it
exactly here but King G5 but now it's
totally different move to Rook D5 and
then moved back because she's not sure
about the move
and back again right
uh it's a good move yeah it clears the
the path for the pawn and the King right
uh normally I would I would advise
players don't reach into the position to
make a move unless you're absolutely
certain you know like to just unhold it
by the way why did she have to go Rook
to D5 why isn't like Rook C5 and you
know uh moving forward The Rook D5 the
reason why I might object I do object to
Rook D5 is because somehow you're
encouraging me to play King F4 King C5
now King C5 now King e
four and I can maybe go B5 Rook C1 King
D6
is that
that is true but yeah I might object to
Rook D5 I think Rook Rook C5 might have
been my choice but we do have the
current situation again apologies I'm
going to just refresh my board King C5
on the board by the way should harika
win this game we're gonna have a
four-way tie for first that's
I mean that's not a lot of Separation at
the top I mean round one four wins but
what a win by Alexandra costing you I'm
going to just say right now that that
game is going to be very hard to beat as
our game of the tournament you know
we're starting with the bank yeah the
checklist yes the whole mating patterns
beginning with Bishop A4 which is
spectacular that was great stuff and
this one
[Music]
uh both players playing on jet lag I'm
sure they're exhausted and playing
rookan games like Almira was mentioning
earlier if you have an extra Pawn it's
hard to win and if you're down upon you
always lose but especially in time
trouble yes mistakes are extremely
common exactly really small section in
endgame books called tragic comedies and
it's about Rook endings and I remember
Mark doing
just making mistakes on every move and
exactly going back and forth winning
draw winning draw right and you we do
have King D6 on the board as now the
white king is ready to escort this Pawn
very straightforward right yes just push
the pawn exactly pushing baby uh B King
King e for B5
and again this king is just great
suddenly actually I'm almost even King
E6 Mighty also even getting greeted yes
yes what's better than being up one Pawn
uh but yeah I think the B Pawn is good
enough B B5
Rook C5 and B6 on White's agenda
it makes a big difference that White
Pond managed to cross the fourth ring
and get to F5 right because we were
talking about The Rook being ideally
placed on F3 when the Pawn's on F5 well
guess what The Rook is ideally placed
right here right now it defends both the
F5 and B5 pawns and it's the B Pawn that
is getting ready to
be escorted to coronation
yeah and if now Rook P1 white can play
King physics
if you go C1 I can just cover Rook C5
because we know that pawn and game is
lost for black because of King D5 roof
exactly easily
and Elizabeth is coming to
grips with the shear
Terror of knowing that she has let a
draw slipped from her grasp she played
Rook C8 again I think it's the most
natural move is Rook C5 in the position
just sidestepping check
and Rook C5 harika has played
didn't take her long at all as time a
factor by the way uh foreign
very very careful and it's it and she's
in cruise control right now because it's
pretty clear that nobody's stopping the
pawn from just marching dare I say
bravely up the board
yeah The Rook C5
so good uh very instructive Rook end
game this game truly
truly
I'm still not 100 sure where why for
example F4 was winning but Rook B6 check
was not right well I can show it to you
yes please
try to understand it because it's it's
very interesting there's a in the game
yes sorry to interrupt you a mirror but
we do have a handshake as Elizabeth
realize there's no stopping the beat
Pond but go ahead please continue
yes let's have a look at this position
so Rook B6 was played and actually a
computer considered this as a draw but I
think the difference is it's very
important well you start by playing F4
let's consider the the simple defense
which actually could have happened in
the game but now after rugby six King F7
you have this move King F5 and so like
you don't have King G6 in order to uh to
hold your own here so after F4 uh you
might start with the King F7 as well but
then you can go king of five so what is
the difference here let's say so after
uh
King F7 so let's say what is going to
happen if you bring your king so here
you have this move Rook F3 right and so
this is a draw so that's like a crucial
difference
because and then you have this maneuver
King King F7 King G6 and I don't have
King F5 either because of Rook F3
exactly and black has the very important
Tempo to play King G6 exactly all the
difference
so that's the difference actually
between a draw and a win wow speaking of
wins may it boldly State the obvious
that we've got four out of five meatloaf
said two out of three ain't bad four out
of five must be amazing
four out of five and here it is our
leaders our standings we have four
co-workers Alexandra Castro new Harry
catranavali kunai mamajada and Irina
Crush all one today only a single draw
one draw between Nana techniza and Anna
zatonski
and even that game
definitely had chances exactly it could
easily have been uh
and tomorrow we're looking at round two
coming tomorrow and the players will be
playing one game a day every day they'll
have one rest day after round five right
same two insane
same time same channel and to take a
look at the policy well be pairings for
tomorrow all right we have conero plane
crash
okay I hope he's gonna say okay I gotta
take you down that's Arena starting with
two blocks
I took ninja playing optimalic right
right uh Bella against zatonsky
there will be no jet lag in that game
pets against Mama Zara right and two
leaders playing each other in Costa nuke
against Jordan Valley right see a
marquee match up on table number five
look at that yeah Alexandra picked one
number one yeah
so she's gonna try to
score again and have a early lead in the
tournament you know it's very strange I
had to double check it but uh I think I
won a return right where I got the
number one wow I picked one every turn I
mean starting with two whites and
finishing with the black your last round
game is black uh is I always felt that
was a huge Edge and I remember
1980 Tata steel the Masters as like I
started with corchinoy and Tim mountain
or something like that and I won both
games and
it was sky's the limit ten and a half
out of 13.
I mean three out of five
but somehow you're you're in great
company
I mean it's not everybody
that you and bar that's that's special I
I I I I admire I mean it was really hard
actually hard to make a choice today I
didn't want to choose between my friends
right so I chose a player who I actually
don't know at all well done very very
well done and again four out of five as
we get uh set up for uh we're hoping
Eureka will come over and join us and
share uh
her her win today it was it was pretty
nice and again I just uh for those of
you who are joining us late uh shame on
you first of all but the final position
just to I I just like to to walk the
plank okay this was the game that
Alexandra played against our defending
uh Champion
um
and we see the king that got blown out
of the water was sitting there on the C7
Square suddenly it's up here in the
center of the board on the E4 Square
knight jump to E6
closer
F5 beautiful touch exactly check
closer you know what I'm upset about the
corner resigned here right allowed to
Checkmate I always allow my opponents to
check my interesting
no interview uh as uh harika is just
exhausted and we can very much imagine
that
Amira you get the final word of today's
game and I know you're being hit with
jet lag as well well I wanted to say
that I'm alive and kick English let's
say I'm awake
well this was a very exciting opening
round because we have four decisive
games and I was looking at this position
Alexandra secretly told me in Russian
that well I had to play native Ford and
it was more beautiful she said yes from
aesthetic point of view so a very
important win for Irena crash with black
because we all know how difficult it is
to start a tournament with black pieces
especially against such a stronger
position so it shows that she is in very
good shape and I think that's well
tomorrow's round especially against
hampicanero I will show if she can
continue and maybe well to hit the spare
or strike absolutely couldn't set it
better I mean uh great start to the
Karen's cup thank you much thank you so
much for joining us tell all your
friends where you're hanging out and we
wish you a happy evening and join us
tomorrow at the same time
[Music]
foreign
this has been a presentation of the St
Louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the St Louis
chess club is prohibited